ليش توجهتوا أصلًا أنكم تصيرون برنامج محاسبي؟
لأن نبي نصير الشريك التقني رقم واحد لتاجر التجزئة
والله رحت، ما في أحد ما حبيت خشمه
عشان يستخدم البرنامج في البداية
ناس كثير والله، بس اللي استخدموه اثنين
ليش؟
والله حب خشوم
تقريبًا هو قرابة الـ 7% من التعاملات السنوية بالتجزئة
الآن يمر من خلال النظام حقنا
7%؟
إيه
من كل تعاملات التجزئة؟
في السعودية؟
بالضبط، تقريبًا نتكلم عن تسعة مليار
احنا قايمين على النمو
متوسط النمو عندنا في المبيعات خلال الأربعة سنوات الماضية
%600 سبعة أضعاف
يلا حيّهم، ضيفنا اليوم مؤسس وحدة من أكبر الشركات
اللي تقدم حلول إدارة المخزون والمبيعات لتجار التجزئة
شركة «رواء» آخر كم سنة
كانت تبيع في السنة الواحدة كمتوسط مبيعات
تقريبًا سبع أضعاف السنة اللي قبلها
وصلت المبيعات من خلال المنصة 9 مليار ريال تقريبًا
وقفلوا مؤخرًا جولة استثمارية بقيمة 100 مليون ريال
فحبيت اليوم أستضيف مؤسسها «محمد القصيّر»
أسولف معه عن تجربته في تأسيس الشركة وتطوير منتجاتها
إلى ما وصلت لشكلها الحالي
الشركة بدأت بنموذج أولي بسيط، برنامج كاشير
ثم قررت تدريجيًا تطور منتجاتها بحيث يصير فيه
برنامج محاسبي، برنامج إدارة مخزون
ومجموعة من الخصائص الثانية
ثم صاروا يبيعون أجهزة لعملائهم مع البرنامج
بدل ما يكتفون بمبيعات البرنامج فقط
وبعدها صاروا يقدمون خدمات مدفوعات بالشراكة مع البنوك
وغيره من الأشياء اللي بنغطيها في الحلقة
خلال هذه التجربة مروا بتحديات كثيرة جدًّا
سواءً في كيف يصممون برنامج مناسب للمحلات بمختلف أنواعها
والمشاكل اللي مرتبطة بالأجهزة السيئة
اللي منتشرة بالمحلات في السوق
اللي كانوا يشتروا منها ويبيعون للعملاء
والصدمة اللي جاتهم يوم اكتشفوا أن كثير من أصحاب المحلات
ما يديرون مبيعاتهم ولا مخزونهم أساسًا بشكل جيد
حلقة اليوم حلقة دسمة ومليانة تفاصيل
عن تطوير المنتجات والتسويق والمبيعات لهذا النوع من المنتجات
فأترككم معها
حيّ الله أبو عساف
الله يحييك، يا هلا وسهلا
تقول لي أن فيه موضوع بس مثير للاهتمام
ودي ندخل فيه قبل ما ندخل في سالفة «رواء»
قبل الحلقة كنا نسولف على هواياتنا وأيش نسوي
تقول لي: ما عندك أي هوايات
والله أحاول أني أتبنى بعض الهوايات
ويعني أقول «أعمال قيد التطوير»
ماخذ وقتك الشغل؟
نوعًا ما
يا أخي ما تحس كذا إذا جلست في لحظة مع نفسك
قلت: يا أخي أنا ليش ما عندي شيء برّا الشغل؟
والله شوف الطريقة اللي أفكر فيها
إذا كان ممتع الشيء اللي قاعد تسويه
وأنت مستمتع فيه
فما أعتقد أنه يكون شغل
فهذا هو المبدأ اللي أعيش فيه
كلام كتب ذا
والله صح، لكن هذا هو الواقع على الأقل
أتذكر أختي قالت لي أول ما جيت من أمريكا
يمكن 2019 أو 2018
فتشوفني أشتغل كثير
فقالت: أبغى أتكلم معك وكذا
بصراحة استغربت شوي، قلت تمام
تصارحك
إيه، فلما جلست قالت: هل عندك أصدقاء؟
أيوة
قلت: لا الحمدلله عندي أصدقاء وكذا
لأنها تشوفني دائمًا اشتغل، فهمت؟
قلت: لا والله عندي أصدقاء ومستمتع بحياتي
عندك حياة؟
هل أنت عندك حياة؟
فالحمدلله، لطالما أن فيه تطور؛ تستمتع
وقبل التطور، حتى لو ما كان فيه تطور
أو حتى ما كان فيه تطور في العمل
طالما أنك مستمتع؛ صدقني ما راح يكون شغل
أنا بشتغل معك بعد الحلقة ترى عن الموضوع ذا إن شاء الله
والله نشوف كيف
أنا أحس أنها ضرورية، أنها كذا متنفس
تصير فيه هوايات
جدًّا ضروري
بالعكس
نضبطك بعدها
طيب أنت ذكرت تو موضوع أمريكا
أنت رحت بعثة في أمريكا
بس برضه سويت مشروع هناك
صحيح
ويبدو لي أنه ما مشت أمورك
إيه صح
كان برضه أجهزة ومرتبطة مع برمجيات
أيش سالفته؟ ما قلت لي عنه
هو قبلها في 2008
كان عندي منتدى على موقع إخباري
و جاء واحد، وقتها توني متعلم البرمجة
وتوّي بادي في الموقع هذا
أيش كنت تدرس في أمريكا؟
كنت أدرس هندسة كهربائية وكمبيوتر
حلو
إيه، وقتها جاء واحد واشترى مني هذا الموقع هذا بمبلغ ممتاز
وكنت وقتها في الثانوية
تقدر تصرح بكم؟
من الثانوي
يعني فوق الخمسين
خمسين ألف دولار؟
لا ريال طبعًا نتكلم
تمام
كان عندنا في السعودية
فاكتشفت أن التقنية تجيب فلوس
إيه والله
وكنت ما أعرف ريادة أعمال ولا أدري أيش السالفة
أيش كان هو؟ منتدى أيش يسوي؟
كان منتدى أخباري على...
يعني كان فيه شوي فكرة جديدة مو منتدى
كان أخبار والناس تعلّق عليه
تكتب عليه تعليقات بناءً على الخبر
ويكتبون محتوى بناءً عليه
فكان فيه فكرة مختلفة
توها تبدأ تكون
يعني توّها تتشكّل الفكرة ولا هي بواضحة
وجاء واحد اشتراها على طول!
تقريبًا بعد سنتين اشتراه
والزيارات كانت ممتازة
أنا ماخذها هواية
فالموضوع صار لا والله ترى السالفة فيها فلوس
حلو
ففتحت عيوني على التقنية تجيب فلوس
بعدها في 2010 أو نهاية 2009
رحت أمريكا ودرست هندرسة كهربائية وكمبيوتر
وبعدين تخرجت، بعد التخرج
لحظة، المنتدى ذا سويته وأنت في أمريكا وللا؟
لا، وأنا في السعودية في الثانوي
وهذا اللي دفعني أصلًا أني أتخصص في التقنية
في الثانوي سويته وجاء واحد واشتراه منك
الله الله
أجنبي وللا سعودي؟
لا، سعودي في السعودية
حلو، اشتراه منك سعودي، وبعدين رحت تدرس
إيه، فبعدها بعد الجامعة
وفي الجامعة كنت مسوي نفسي
عندي تجربة على الأقل تعتبر
خلاص معك مشروع ما يحتاج
وهذه المشكلة هي ترى
شفت نفسك
جاهز أني أبدأ التجربة حقتي
فدخلت وقلنا يلا بسم الله
أنا وواحد من الشباب في الجامعة بعد التخرج
بدينا شركة أجهزة وبرامج
التقنية شوي معقدة
الفكرة منها أنك تصور جسمك ثلاثي الأبعاد
وبعدين أعطيك حسابات دقيقة عن جسمك وإلى آخره
بحيث أن أفيد الناس حقين النادي
الناس الصحيين
يعني أيش توريني الدهون؟
بالضبط الدهون
والعضلات
العضلة وهذه التفاصيل
أيش اللي فشّلها؟
كان فيه أجهزة وبرمجيات
كانت وقتها نهاية 2015 ومنتصف 2016
يعني أبطينا والله واحنا نبني المنتج
طلع المنتج الأولي، لكن كان عندنا أمل
أن الآيفون أبو ثلاث كاميرات هذا بيطلع
كان فيه أخبار
سنة كم هذه؟
سنة تقريبًا 2016
أيش كنتوا تستخدمون من قبل الآيفون؟
كنا احنا اللي سوينا نظام كامل، أجهزة وبرمجيات
كاميرات
الميزان وكاميرات ثلاثية الأبعاد
وكان بصراحة غالي التثبيت أغلى من قيمة الآيفون
فكنا نقول أنه بعد ما يجي الآيفون
بتصير التقنية رخيصة
ننتظر الآيفون
طلعنا بالنموذج المبدئي وبدينا نشتغل
لكن كانت التقنية فعلًا مكلفة
وفيه تصنيع وفيه تفاصيل
خل نقول أن التجربة هذيك أدبتني
أنه لا تبالغ في التقنيات والتوقعات
هو تحدي، ولا أقطع واردك
تحدي كبير إذا أنت بتحاول تقدم الجهاز والبرمجيات
عكس ناس كثير الحين
مثلًا يسوي له متجر إلكتروني وللا برنامج وكذا
فهو برمجيات بس
بس أنك تسوّي الأجهزة والبرمجيات
فهذا تحدي كبير
بالضبط
ورجعت سويتها أنت مرة ثانية
إيه
بس مشت معك
بس عاد مرة ثانية سويناها بطريقة مختلفة
لا وكنت أقاتل أنه ما نسويه، فبنجيها
لكن اللي صار أنه ما ضبطت السالفة
انتظرنا آيفون، أعلنوا عن الآيفون اللي في 2016
ما نزل
ما طلع فيه ثلاث كاميرات
ما طلع ثلاثة كاميرات صار صراحة شوي إحباط
قلنا بنكمل إلين 2017 ونشوف
وكملنا شغل، كنت أشتغل طبعًا
وكان عندي هذا التثبيت
جات 2017 وبرضه ما نزل الآيفون الثلاث كاميرات
ثلاث كاميرات على أساس تعطيك
ثلاثي الأبعاد عشان التقنية تصير ممتازة
عشان التقنية تصير برمجيات بدل ما هي الاثنين
هل هو ثلاث كاميرات وللا فيه تقنية الـ«لايدار»؟
لا، الثلاث كاميرات تحديدًا
لأنه عشان يصور ثلاثي الأبعاد
فهي السالفة أنه...
طبعًا الحساس مهم، ولكن الأساس بالكاميرات
وليش قررت أنت بعدين
أنا ما ودي صراحة أطول كثير في القصة
أبي أعرف أيش اللي خلاك تقرر أن تبدأ من أول؟
التقنية غالية، فخلاص قررت أني ارجع السعودية
وحمسني وقتها الحراك والوضع اللي صاير في السعودية
ريادة أعمال وفلة
إيه، وصار فيه حراك
صار فيه شوي جدية في الأمور
فقلت: تدري أجل خيرة، خل نرجع السعودية
رجعنا السعودية على نهاية تقريبًا 2017
القصة الصدق أنها ما تحمس كيف بدينا «رواء»
ولكن بكل بساطة يعني كانت عملية شوي
صرت أبحث أيش هو...
ما أبي أسوي أجهزة، خلاص أبي أشتغل بالبرمجيات
ولا أبي يتوظف أبي أركز
يعني أنا كنت أشتغل في أمريكا وكان عندي شركة ناشئة
والنقطة الثالثة أن يكون سوق كبير
لأن السوق اللي سويناه كان برضه صغير
كان بس نعطيه للنادي
فكان خلاص غطينا النوادي اللي في المدينة
فما صار عندي عملاء زيادة
لازم أسافر عشان أبيع لعملاء زيادة
فكان فيه تحدي كبير
فقلت: لا خلاص
لازم يكون سوق كبير وبرمجيات
برمجيات فقط
إيه. نقطة أنه يكون برمجيات وما يكون أجهزة
ترى نقطة خلنا نقول أنها كانت نقطة...
خلنا نتفق بأنها برمجيات وأجهزة
عشان ما نخليها «هارد وير» و«سوفت وير»
فهي «برمجيات» و «أجهزة»
ونقطة ثالثة، أني ما أبغى أشتغل
فرجعت السعودية صرت أحلل الأسواق
أيش السوق اللي مو مخدوم بشكل جيد
مو مخدوم بشكل جيد
بالضبط مو مخدوم بشكل جيد
وفي نفس الوقت أن فيه فرصة كبيرة للنمو
فطاح عيني على التجارة الإلكترونية
وكنت أقرأ تقرير
لوزارة الاتصالات أو هيئة الاتصالات
كان يقول: أن في ذاك الوقت 1.9% أو 0.9%
من التجزئة: تجارة إلكترونية
فوضح أن فيه فرصة كبيرة في القطاع
أنت قلت لي عن طريقة اللي إذا تدخل في سوق
سوّي استفتاء على نسبة الرضا
بالضبط
هذه وشلون سويتوها؟
بشكل عشوائي شوي
تروح تسأل الناس أيش رأيك في البرنامج اللي معك؟
أو أيش رأيك في الخدمة الفلانية؟
وتقيّمه من 1-10؟
إيه، هل ممكن ينصحني أني آخذ نفس الخدمة اللي يستخدمها وللا لا؟
إذا قال لك لا؛ فاعرف أن فيه رضا منخفض
فبالتالي واحدة من الأشياء اللي اشتغلنا عليها
كان أن الناس مو براضية عن الخدمة
بس قبلها القطاع، كيف حددنا القطاع؟
كيف أنه خلاص بشتغل في القطاع هذا
حلو، فأنت لو بنخليها بشكل مبسط للناس
تبي تشوف فيه فرصة في سوق معين
تشوف من اللاعبين اللي موجودين في السوق
تروح عند العملاء هذولي
استفتهم في استخدام نسبة الرضا وتقيم من 1-10
اللي هو قِس مستوى الرضا عن الخدمة
تسألهم إلى أي درجة يمكن ينصحون فيها أحد ثاني
وبعدين تأخذ تقييماتهم وتشوف
طبعًا هذه بحسبة سريعة سويتوها أنتم
بالضبط إيه فهذه أسهل شيء
إذا فيه عدم رضا عام؛ معناته فيه فرصة هنا للتطوير
صح
أنكم تقدمون الخدمة
حلو
نجي للأخير، خلنا نقول لقينا فرصة مثلًا في التجارة الإلكترونية
بدينا نسوي للناس مواقع
اكشفنا الناس تخلي شغلها
يعني بعد فترة تترك المتجر الإلكتروني
فعرفت أن ماهي مشكلة المتجر الإلكتروني
صارت لنا المشكلة شوي أكبر
أنه أصلًا ما يقدر يسوّق بعد التجارة الإلكترونية
بعدين طلعت فكرة أنه خلاص
توقعنا أن هذه الفكرة هي اللي بتكسر الدنيا
أن أيش هو؟
بعطيك مخزون وبخليك تربط وقتها
مع «سوق» و«وادي» والتفاصيل هذه
وتبيع الأشياء هذه كلها بضغطة زر
قلنا بسم الله
بدينا نربط مع «سوق» إلا صار استحواذ «سوق»
وقالوا لنا «سوق» خلاص
أرسلوا لنا بريد إلكتروني
والله ما أنسى ذاك البريد الإلكتروني
قالوا: خلاص ترى بنوقف الربط
وروحوا وشوفوا مع «أمازون» خلاص
يا جماعة الخير كأن المشروع صفّر من جديد
الشركاء وقتها ثلاثة، قالوا: خلاص السلام عليكم، تدري
واضح مو بماشية
إيه هذه مو بماشية
سبحان الله، قلت له: تمام بكمل لحالي
بديت شوي شوي، جاني واحد من الشباب
كنا في «بادر» في ذاك الوقت
جاني وقال لي: طيب أنت أيش رؤيتك؟
وأتذكر أني قبل ثلاثة شهور قايل لواحد من الشركاء
أنه احنا نبي نصير بعد أربع سنين «إي آر بي»
نبي نبدأ من مخزونك يصير في «وادي» و«سوق» وهذه
ونتطور في أننا بنقدم نقاط بيع ومحاسبة
ويشمل عن الخدمات اللوجستية
يعني خطة مكتملة للأركان
شركة كبرى في أربع سنين
وأربع سنوات بيكون لدينا «إيه آر بي» للتجزئة
الـ «إيه آر بي» أيش هو بس؟
الـ «إيه آر بي» اللي هو البرنامج اللي فيه إدارة الموارد حق الشركة
اللي يكون فيه محاسبة ونقاط بيع وإدارة الخدمات اللوجستية
والمخزون
والمخزون والتفاصيل هذه
فكان فيه رؤية حالمة إتجاه أنها في أربع سنوات
بنكمل هذه الأشياء
بالأخير هذا الربط على طول وئد في لحظته
سبحان الله، بعد قراري أني بكمل
واحد من الشاب اللي «بادر»
قال لي ابدأ من الكاشير
إذا كان العملاء أصلًا يعانون من قضية الكاشير
ومن قضية أساسًا أنه لما تجي تقول له
تعال ويلا بيع عبر الإنترنت
يقولك: أساسًا أنا ما أعرف أيش يصير في الفرع عندي
فكمل على اللي أنت بعت عليه
وشلون تنط خطوة وتوديني عبر الإنترنت على طول
بالضبط، أنا عندي مشاكل أكبر أصلًا في هذا، ليش ما تكمل؟
كذا جاني شعور أنه يا أخي فكرة الكاشير ما تحمس
وهذه ترى أكبر المشكلة عند التقنيين العرب
كثير، يا أخي ممل شكله
وشلون كاشير؟ يا أخي مو بحماس
لا نبغى ضغطة زر ومنتجك يصير في كل مكان
قصة حلوة
نفس غلطتك حق أمريكا
بالضبط، والله العظيم
شيء مبهر
وفعليًّا جاني استرجاع على قصة أمريكا، تخيل!
يا أخي مو بلازم القصة تصير حماس
لا، ترى ممكن أنه فعلًا يحل المشكلة الأكبر بالنسبة للعميل
بس وقتها السوق ما كان زحمة
هذا 2018 أو 2017؟
منتصف 2018
ما كان السوق زحمة؟
اليوم مثلًا في مليون ألف كاشير في السوق
لا، كان أغلب السوق ترى مو سحابي
كان أغلبهم اللي بـ 500 ريال اللي حراج الكمبيوتر
كان هذا الأغلب
اللي أحيانًا تروح تشتري منهم نظام على «ويندوز»
يبيعون لك الجهاز
الجهاز مع البرنامج
تحط كذا كمبيوتر، عندك في المحل
بالضبط، ولا وصول ولا شيء
وفيه برنامج غير متصل
واستمتع
ويجيك اللي يدربك على النظام
أنا مريت فيها شخصيًّا التجربة ذي
يجي يقولك: ترى على فكرة 5% بس من المزايا تحتاجها
باقي الأشياء هذه كلها ما تحتاجها
عجيب!
يدربك على كم شغلة
تسأله، طيب فيه سبعين أيقونة ثانية
لا ما تحتاجها
إيه ما عليك
هذه ركز عليها هي اللي تحتاج
هذا الأسلوب اللي فعليًّا يوم جينا السوق كان كذا
كان أغلب السوق كذا
ولا كان فيه وعي بقضية السحابي
سبحان الله اتخذت القرار
واللي طمعني، طبعًا هو كان برمجي
قلت له: أيش رأيك تبدأ معي طيب؟
أنا استلم واجهات وأنت تستلم واجهات؟
قال لي: تم
من هو ذا؟
صاحبي اللي في «بادر»
كيف؟
هو كان عنده شركة في «بادر» «8 تك»
حلو تقنيات تعليمية
إيه، قال لي: أبد يلا تم
وبدينا أنا وياه في قضية أني خلاص
بنحط نموذج الكاشير وبنخدم قضية الكاشير
طيب رجعت أجهزة وبرمجيات مرة ثانية
لا، ما نبيع أجهزة فقط برمجيات
خلاص أنت يا راعي البقالة وللا المحل عندك جهازك
احنا بس نتزل عليه برنامجنا
أيوة
النقطة المهمة هنا ومن الأشياء اللي حمستنا أصلًا
وأنا كنت أناقشه
أنه فعليًّا فيه عدم رضا على الوضع اللي كان موجود هناك
البرامج تضيع
مثلًا البيانات حقتك لو ضربت الكمبيوتر؛ تضيع
تفاصيل كثيرة و لما أقول له: أيش رأيك بالكاشير؟
يقول لي: يا ابن الحلال أموره طيبة
يمشينا
بالضبط، أنه كان وضحت الفرصة مرة
فتنازلت عن شعور...
وكان فيه فرصة
فيه شركة أذكر مسيطرة على السوق
ما أدري إذا لليوم أو لا
اللي هي «يمن سوفت» الظاهر اسمها
إيه، طبعًا هو غيروا العلامة التجارية حقهم
لكنه ما زالت موجودة في السوق
بس أنها استهدفت فئة جديدة ومختلفة
بس ما زالت موجودة أتوقع
اسلم
الكلام وين؟ الكلام أنه يوم بدينا في الكاشير
اكتشفنا أنه لا
فعليًّا الناس محتاجة هذا البرنامج أكثر بكثير
من الربط والفلسفة هذه، واضح؟
فمع احترامي لـ...
فمشينا فيه
كان فكرته أنه ما ودنا نسوي جمع مستثمرين
إلين يصير عندي منتج أولي
يوم خلاص حطينا جدول زمني معين
ليش؟
فكرة أنك تسوي جمع مستثمرين
وأنت ما عندك منتج؛ أنا أعتقد أنها كارثية
أنك تجيب استثمار  قبل ما يكون عندك منتج مثلًا
إلى درجة أنه ما كان فيه فلوس والله
ليش طيب؟
لأن لابد تثبت مدى قدرتك على إنشاء شركة بأقل الموارد
حلو، أيش تتوقع هذا ينعكس على موضوع المستثمرين؟
فأنت عندك متوسط القدرة على إنشاء شركة بدون موارد
عشان أنا أثق وأعطيك فلوسي بالبداية
فالمستثمر بالأساس، بالغالب يعطيك فلوس
عشان فيه شوية نار، ويزود على النار شوي أنها تصير نار كبيرة
مو بأنه يبيك تتعلم على فلوسه
بالغالب ماهو بهذا أو على الأقل الوضع في الدول الناضجة
إيه كذا المفروض مو لأنك تنشئ منتج من الصفر
أجي وأعطيك فلوس
وغير كذا في 2018 الوضع كان مختلف شوي
مو مثل الحين، الحين فيه توزيع فلوس شوي
لا، طبعًا الوضع مختلف
في الدول اللي مثلنا
واحنا تونا باديين وكذا في الشغلات
حتى في 2018 و 2019 كان أكيد الوضع مختلف
كان الفلوس في كل مكان
وكان سهل بالنسبة لي صراحة
ترى موضوع الفلوس ما كان صعب
بس كان التجربة أنه كان المبدأ غلط
بس أنت قعدت تقريبًا من 2018 - 2020
لا 2019
احنا أطلقنا في يناير 2019 ما طولنا
لنا أربع شهور وأطلقنا المنتج
بديتوا متأخر في 2018؟
إيه، جلسنا أربعة شهور
قعدتوا سنة بس عشان تسوون نموذج أولي؟
إيه، صحيح، تسعة شهور تقريبًا
نموذج أولي
بشهر ثلاثة أو أربعة تقريبًا بدينا بشكل فعلي
أول سطر برمجي كتبناه كان في شهر أربعة
حلو، كم عميل حاولتوا تثبتون الفكرة معه
قبل ما تكلمون مستثمرين؟
بعنا أكثر من عميل وما استعمل البرنامج
بس وضح أن البرنامج مباع من وقت قريب
وضحت أن البرنامج راح ينباع
المهم أنه كان من عملائكم، بس البداية
أنت الحين عشان الشخص اللي يبغى يسوي
نموذج أولي لمنتج في محل
من أول ناس كلمتوهم؟
والله رحت ما في أحد ما حبيت خشمه
عشان يستخدم البرنامج بالبداية
ناس كثير والله بس اللي استخدموه اثنين
ليش؟
والله حب خشوم، فزعة
هذا التفسير الوحيد
ولا كملوا؟
أول شيء أنا على أساس أني بدفعهم فلوس
واحد قال: خذ قراشيعك، وتكفى لا تجي
ثم قلت خلاص مجانًا
ثم استخدموه فترة ثم جدعوه
وبدينا كملنا الشغل، بس خلاص وضح أن البرنامج بدأ شوي
يصير قابل للاستخدام في يناير
وقتها صرت أدور واحد مالي عشان نسوي جمع مستثمرين
تدور واحد
مالي
مالي عشان موضوع الاستثمار
ومعارف وأسوي مقابلات وما أدري شلون
وأخذت لي كم دورة بالمحاسبة
عشان أعرف أيش السالفة
وأقابل شريكي «عبدالله الجضعي»
عن طريق توصية، وللا أساس أني بسوي معه مقابلة
وبعد نص المقابلة
قال: أيش الأسئلة دي؟ خل نرتقي
هو أيش تخصصه «عبدالله»؟
«عبدالله» مالية
إيه مالية هو
إيه بالضبط، ما شاء الله تبارك الله
ورجال مالي قوي
فبالتالي كان مضيعة وقت
وحافظ لي أنا المصفوفة حق الـ«ساس»
وترويج المجهز فيها
فجاي أول أتفلسف عليه
والرجال قد سوّى جمع مستثمرين قبل وعنده...
و جاي من أمريكا والرجال فاهم ما شاء الله تبارك الله
أنا عندي اعتراض صراحة
شفت يوم جلسنا ذاك اليوم
يوم أزوركم في الشركة
إيه؟
ترى طول الوقت الوقت أحسبه المدير التقني
لا!
ما جاب طاري الفلوس نهائيًّا
ما غير يتكلم عن البرمجيات
طبعًا «عبدالله» هو فعليًّا الآن ماسك القسم التقني في الشركة
تمام
بس أنه متعدد المواهب
فترى يكتب كود هو
أوه بعد؟
إيه
ما شاء الله مالية وتقنية
وكود وكل شيء وتشغيل واللي تبي
ما شاء الله
فالفكرة وأنا أسولف وإياه
وقال لي: خل نرتقي بمستوى الحديث شوي
فعرفت أنه هذا الرجال اللي أنا أبيه
فصارت المقابلة بدل ماهي مقابلة
صارت أني أقوله أيش رأيك تدخل معي
خل نرتقي، أيش كنت تقول له أنت؟
لا، أنا كنت أسأله مثلًا على أشياء
بدائية يعني
مثل «قيمة عمر العميل» (Lifetime Value)
وهي أشياء بسيطة تُعتبر
فهو يحس عطني شيء أعمق
إذا فيه شيء مثلًا نسولف، خل نستغل الوقت
فعرفت أن هذا اللي نبيه
فعرضت عليه شراكة يعني وللا؟
إيه، فصارت السالفة أيش رأيك تصير شريكي؟
فبالتالي فعلًا مع الوقت وذا خلاص وافق
ودخل في البداية أنه بيختبرنا شوي
وريناه المنتج وقلنا ترى خلاص جاهزين
طبعًا احنا مو جاهزين ولا شيء
بس أن ترى هذا المنتج الحين مسألة وقت
ونصير شركة مليارية
فوافق، وقال: استعنا بالله. وبدأ معنا
قعد شهر، طيب أيش التوجه؟
ليش احنا نبي تمويل عشان نجمع جولة استثمارية
بعنا أول عميل
أول ما بعنا أول عميل، قلت له
«عبدالله» الآن أنا أعتقد أن هذه الوقت المثالي
أن احنا نجمع جولة استثمارية
وفعلًا، طبعًا أول عميل ما زال موجود معنا إلى اليوم
بس أول عميل، أيش اللي تغيّر ما بين النموذجي الأولي وأول عميل؟
يعني أيش خلّى أول عميل فعلًا يتبنى؟
نضج البرنامج شوي، يعني صار يشتغل
ما فيه أخطاء الأرقام
صار فيه أساسيات في المخزون
وصار فيه أساسيات بالكاشير وصفحة المبيعات وكذا
صار فيه أساسيات يعني
فأنتم تعلمتم من النموذج الأولي كل النواقص هذه
بالضبط
خليناه أصغر نسخة قابلة للاستخدام
لو تشوفها تقول: أيش اللعب ذا؟
بس الحمد لله مشت
فأول ما قفلنا هذا
ونروح للمستثمرين ونقول لهم: ترى هذه البداية الآن
طموحنا أن احنا خلال أربع سنوات نوصل...
ولا وصلتوا
وبعد تقريبًا خمس سنوات أحب أقول لك لك
أن 30% من الرؤية تحققت
الحمد لله، زين
فهذه كانت البداية بشكل كامل
الخطط عمومًا الطويلة ذي
مو بدايم تحقق بنفس الطريقة المكتوبة
بس أنا ودي الحين نبدأ نفصل«رواء» شوي
بدل ما ناخذها كقصة ناخذها كأجزاء
نسولف فيها للناس اللي مهتمين في القطاع هذا
لو واحد بيسوي مشروع
لو واحد بيتعلم من تجربتكم
ويأخذ كل موضوع على حدة
بس قبل ما ندخل بالتفصيل على هذا
ودي تشرح لي اليوم «رواء» أيش هو؟
أيش تسوون بالضبط
لو تتذكر قلنا بالبداية أن منتجنا الأولي
صار برنامج كاشير وإدارة مخزون مخصص للتجزئة
اختلفت شوي، الآن اختلف المنتج
مثل ما قلنا الرؤية، نرجع لموضوع الرؤية
صرنا الحين برنامج محاسبي
فاليوم أيش نسوي؟
ما تشوف نفسك كاشير، أنت تشوف نفسك برنامج محاسبي أكثر
اليوم إيه
وعندنا الميزة اللي احنا مختلفين فيها عن البرامج الثانية
أننا نربط مع المتاجر الإلكترونية بطريقة مرة ممتازة
ففرعك يصير على الإنترنت
نفس الفكرة الأولى اللي احنا بدينا فيها وماتت
تمام، بس أنت اليوم تشوف نفسك من زاوية محاسبية
أكثر من زاوية إدارة محل أو إدارة مبيعات
لا، هو جزء من إدارة المحل
إذا كبرت لازم يصير عندك برنامج محاسبي
أنا فهمت أن أنت تنظر لنفسك برنامج محاسبي أكثر
لأنك الحين رابط فيه المخزون ومبيعات الفرع وكل شيء
بالضبط
فأنت تقدم نفسك كبرنامج محاسبي أكثر
البرنامج المحاسبي للتجزئة لازم يصير فيه الكاشير
ولازم يصير فيه المخزون
لأنك تاخذ كل النقاط اللي قاعد يحاول فيه
إيه فأنا جالس أقفله
فأي شيء يبيه عميلي جالس أخدمه
هذه هي الرؤية، هذه هو التوجه لعملية تطوير المنتج
وليش توجهتوا أصلًا أنكم تصيرون برنامج محاسبي؟
لأن نبي نصير الشريك التقني رقم واحد لتاجر التجزئة
ومنها بعد تربطونه من كل مكان
بالضبط، يا سلام عليك
فجالسين نكبر مع العميل
العميل والله الآن يبي برنامج محاسبي
جالس أعطيه برنامج محاسب وبكمل معه
وبكمل مع العميل
يعني الحين الناس يقولوا: يا أخي لا تتشتت
لا، التشتت مختلف
إذا مثلًا والله بقول أني أبغى أصير أخدم
مثلًا حقين الاستشارات الهندسية
في قضية حساب عدد الساعات
إيه مالها علاقة
لا هنا مالها دخل
إيه، هنا أنا شطحت
بس أنت تكون في البداية تبدأ كاشير
بعدين تكتشف أنه مثلًا يقول لك
طيب تربط مع البرنامج اللي عندي حق كذا؟
تقول: طيب ليش ما أبدأ أقدم الخدمة هذه
بالضبط
وهكذا إلين ما تتعمق أكثر في الخدمات اللي تقدمها
هو في رؤية
وتصير تستبدل الخدمات اللي يستخدمونها اليوم
أيوة
يصير يتخلص من البرنامج المحاسبي
يصير يتخلص من برنامج المخزون
يصير يتخلص من...
خلنا نقول بديل جيد
أو تربط معه
أو نربط معه مثلًا
أنت عندك الخيارين
يا تربط مع البرامج اللي عنده أو تستبدلها
فخلنا ناخذ «رواء» جزء جزء
عندك موضوع الأجهزة
أنتم اليوم تبيعون الجهاز مع البرمجيات طبعًا حقه
برمجيات «رواء»
أيش اللي خلاك تقول أنا ببدأ أبيع أجهزة
بدل ما أعتمد على الأجهزة اللي موجودة في السوق
أني ما أروح للمحلات
خلاص أنت عندك تابلت وللا عندك جهاز «ويندوز»
أنا بصير موجود عليه
أيش اللي خلّاك تبيع أجهزة؟
احنا صرنا نسحب من السوق
وصرنا نغيّر الموردين من وقت للثاني
يجي عميلي يزعل ويقول: خذ البرنامج هذا خلاص معاد أبيه
ليش؟
اكتشف أن المشكلة بالجهاز اللي معه
جهازه مو بقاعد يشغّل البرمجيات
ضعيف مرة
ولأن احنا نشتغل عن طريق متصفح
فأثقل على الرام
فبالتالي صار بطيء معه
فيتوقع أن البرنامج هو اللي بطيء
بس جهازه هو اللي يكون المشكلة
إيه، لو تقول اليوم أيش أكبر مشكلة يشتكون منها عملائك
يقولون: والله بطيء البرنامج
مع أنه على أجهزتنا والأجهزة زينة
لا بالعكس مرة ممتاز
أن هو يكون أصلًا يستخدم جهاز مورد ثاني عطاه إياه
لا، ومواصفاته مرة منخفضة الجهاز
عشان يطلع له تكلفة أقل
منخفضة، لأن التاجر ما يحسب الحسبة هذه
طيب تمام، أنا رحت واشريت من السوق
يجي يقول مثلًا
والله هذه الذاكرة أربعة
المواصفات ممتازة وبناءً على الفحص اللي أنا أسويه
يقول لك: أن شغلك ممتاز
وبعدين إذا جيت واكتشف
أكتشف أنه صح المواصفات صحيحة
لكن تلقى أجزاء الجهاز غلط
تلقاه شاري مستعمل من مصنع الصين
شاري مثلًا الذاكرة من أجهزة أُتلفت
وللا تلاقي الشاشة وللا المعالج يسمونه اليد الثانية
اللي هو يعني شارينهم بالسوق الثاني
مستخدم
بالضبط مستخدم
تمام المواصفات ممتازة
بس رديئة الأجهزة
بس رديئة
فبالتالي وصلنا مرحلة
أنه يا حبيبي لا بد عشان العميل يكون راضي عنك بشكل تام
لابد أنك تمسك الدورة من أولها
وكان فيه ضغط علينا أن احنا ندخل السوق هذا
بحكم التجربة حق الأجهزة
فعليًّا تعقدت، أكره الأجهزة بشكل ما تتخيل
فحاربنا إلى آخر لحظة
يا جماعة الخير ما نبي أجهزة، فهمت قصدي؟
حتى بيعيقك شوي في التوسع
أنه تحتاج توصل له جهاز وبرمجيات
بالظبط
مو بمثل إذا عنده أجهزة خاصة فيه
لا، بس احنا أيش هو؟
اكتشفنا وسوينا حركة
لما صرنا نشتري من الموردين
ونقول العميل يلا معه الجهاز
المبيعات أتذكر ارتفعت 33% أو شيء مثل كذا
العميل يبي أنه خلاص أبي أشتري البرنامج
وأبي معه الجهاز حقه بسرعة
خلاص إيه تشغله
هذا السبب أن ما عنده جهاز
وللا السبب أنه يبغى جهاز أفضل؟
السبب هو أنه بالغالب يا يبي جهاز أفضل
والله أن الظاهر الاثنين، بس ما عندي أرقام
فيه ناس ما عندهم، وفيه ناس يبونه
فبدايةً كنتم تاخذون أجهزة من أجهزة الكمبيوتر الشخصي وللا الأندرويد؟
لا، كنا نأخذ جهاز كمبيوتر
لأن احنا متصفح، فكنا نأخذ كمبيوتر
والكلام وين؟
صار العميل أصلًا يلزمني يقول لي
إذا أنت تبيني أفعّل بسرعة البرنامج
أبي جهاز
حلو، بس يبقى جزئية الإنترنت بعد
هذه دخلنا فيها
وطبعًا صار فيه شراكة مع «إس تي سي» بنجي فيها
طيب خلنا على الأجهزة الحين
إيه خلنا على الأجهزة
حبيت أنك صرت المحاور، اسلم
لأن أحس أني أقول أشياء كثيرة
اسلم
إيه، موضوع الأجهزة بعدما خلاص تعبنا صراحة
كنا تدري، بعد نقاش طويل وكذا
قلنا خلاص نبي نروح للصين
وطبعًا احنا أخذناه عادة
يعني لا بدينا بشيء
لابد أن نحرص أن يكون بأعلى جودة ممكنة
والله ونجيب لنا من الشباب
مدير منتج عنده تجربة
أجنبي عنده تجربة ممتازة مرة بالأجهزة
وأيضًا ناس من الفريق عندنا طلعوا الصين
والله هو أسس الشركة ومسكنا خط إنتاج
أسستوا شركة؟
إيه أسسنا شركة بالصين
ليش؟
خلاص احنا ترى إذا دخلنا بشي لازم أن يكون...
يعني لازم نقدم تجربة مثالية للعميل بالأخير
إيه حلو الكلام ذا جميل
بس ليش تسوي شركة في الصين؟
لأن أبي أصنّع في الصين وأجيبه للسعودية
بس ما يحتاج تسوي شركة
قصدك أنه على طول أورد؟
إيه، يعني تقدر تتعامل مع مصنع
يعني نوع من أنواع الحوكمة
يعني هي لها علاقة بالحوكمة
لأنه احنا أخذنا خط إنتاج
يعني احنا ما شرينا من واحد، فهمت قصدي؟
يعني احنا شرينا خط إنتاج كامل
أنا ماني شايف الربط بين احتياج أنك تسوي شركة وأنك...
يعني كأني أنا ملكت خط الإنتاج نفسه
كأني أنا ملكت المصنع نفسه
بس طبعًا أنا ما ملكت المصنع
بس خلاص أنا شاري خط إنتاج كامل
حلو، خلنا نتجاوز النقطة هذه
ونهتم بالأجهزة أكثر
رحنا للصين وصار عندنا خط إنتاج حقنا
وتأكدنا من كل شيء
يعني اشتغلنا بقضية...
ليش تصنعون أجهزتكم؟
فيه أجهزة كثير بالسوق
بالصين؟
بالسعودية قصدك؟
لا، سواءً بالسعودية وللا برّا
موجهة أصلاً أنها تكون ككاشير
سواءً كجهاز كمبيوتر أو أجهزة تابلت وللا...
صارت لنا قصة مؤلمة
خلانا مرة ناخذ الموضوع هذا بجدية
دفعنا بالسوق وشرينا من واحد من الموردين
كنا نتعامل معه، جلسنا تقريبًا ثمانية شهور ونحن نتعامل معه
وكان فيه شكاوى بسيطة على الأجهزة حقه
كمبيوتر كان؟
إيه، بس كانت منطقية حق الكاشير، كمبيوتر الكاشير
قلنا خلاص يلا بنطلب منه 500 جهاز
اللي صار، قال: تم
جاب من الصين
صارت الأجهزة اللي جابها لنا
غير اللي بالعادة نشتريها منه
تخيل أن تقريبًا الـ 500 جهاز كلها فشلت
يعني كلها يا رجعناه
يا العميل قاعد يشتكي، ودفعنا احنا من جيبنا للعميل
وغيّرنا له الجهاز بجهاز ثاني
فكانت تجربة مريرة
كانت خسارة، مو بسيطة الصراحة
فهذا ولّد غضب داخلي، يعني شوي
أنه نبي ندخل ونغيّر السوق هذا
نبي نطلع كل ...
بس فيه موردين أجهزة ثانيين
اللي هم يستهدفون الكاشيرات مثل «سونمي»
وناس ثانيين في السوق
لا، «سونمي» نجحوا ببعض الأجهزة
لكن مو بكل الأجهزة
أيش الأجهزة اللي تتوقع نجحوا فيها أكثر من الأجهزة الثانية؟
المحمولة باليد أكثر شيء
اللي هي الصغيرة؟
إيه، وأعتقد سبب نجاحهم أن «إس تي سي»
هي اللي قاعدة تبيع لهم
ولكن أيضًا قضية الجودة وقضية السعر
كانت مهمة بالنسبة لي
لأنه لازم أخلي عميلي ما يخسر بالأجهزة
لأن الأجهزة مو باللي أكسب منه، فبالتالي
أنت ما تبغاه يدفع كثير عليه
ما أبي يدفع كثير، وأبغاه يجيب أفضل جودة
«سونمي» طبعًا اللي أتوقع كثير ناس شافوه
في المطاعم والمحلات غالبًا هو اللي يستقبل طلبات
توصيل
حقت تطبيقات التوصيل
فهو شركة صينية تتعامل عادةً مع وكيل محلي
اللي هو «إس تي سي» حاليًا
بحيث أنه يورد الاجهزة هذه وتورد للشركات
صح، فهو أشياء بسيطة فهمت
التجزئة مو مناسب له مرة
أجل أيش اللي ناسبكم؟
أنا أشوفكم يوم مريت عندكم المكتب
كان عندكم مليون جهاز
صح، سوينا اختبارات
يعني فعليًّا سوينا معمل متكامل عشان موضوع الأجهزة
معمل حق اختبارات
بالضبط
لكن الغضب هذا فعلًا جاب نتيجة بالأخير
أنتم الحين جربتم مجموعة أجهزة في السوق
اللي شفتها يوم أزور شركتكم
إيه، أي جهاز يخطر على بالك من أي مورد جربناه
واكشفتوا كلها ما تصلح؟
فيه رداءة، يعني ماهو بأفضل خيار لعميلي
يعني قضية أنك تقدم منتج لعميلك
أنت تقدم تجربة متكاملة الأركان
أنت ما لقيت شيء يوازن
ما بين سعر المناسب للعميل والجودة
وبنفس الوقت، ترى العميل متطلب
وطبعًا يحق له
وبجي على موضوع العميل
ولكن أنا أبي تجربة كاملة
فلازم أن العميل ما يقول لي أي شيء
فبدينا والله، ودخلنا فيها
وكانت الصراحة تجربة رهيبة
فرحت تصنع جهاز بناءً على مواصفاتك
إيه على مواصفاتي وعلى تجربتي
وصار عندي حتى فريق بالصين
اللي يناظر خط الإنتاج
من يوم ما يشترون القطع إلين يوصل السعودية
في عدة شركات تختبر كل مرحلة
نتأكد أن هذه النتيجة احنا نبيها
تأدبنا صراحة تجربة الـ 500 جهاز هذه
صنعت منا... وتعاملنا مع الموضوع بقسوة
والتوجه حقنا هو
هي أجهزة كمبيوتر مو تابلت
بالضبط، احنا الآن باديين بكمبيوتر
وبنشوف مع الوقت، لكن...
يعني كل جهاز الآن تعطون للعملاء أجهزتكم؟
أجهزتنا
تصنعونها بأنفسكم؟
إيه
أيش ميزتها عن اللي موجود في السوق؟
أن سعرها جدًّا منخفض
نحن تقريبًا نبيع بسعر التكلفة ترى
هامش جدًّا منخفض
والجودة بأعلى مواصفات ممكن تلقاه
على مواصفات جدًّا عالية
فبالتالي بالسوق السعر العادل للجهاز هذا يمكن 2800
بس ليش أنا كذا؟
لأني أنا ما أهتم بالأجهزة
أنا بس أبي عميلي يقول
أن البرنامج هذا رهيب مرة
فاضطريت أني أدخل السوق هذا
فأنت إذا ما عندك بتصرف كثير على الأجهزة كذا وللا كذا
تسوي خط إنتاج أفضل
أرخص لي، بيطلع أرخص بواجد
بعدما انقرصت في الـ 500
بالضبط. بعد التجربة القاسية ذي
لا وبنجي للسوق وبنعطي للناس
حتى أن بالجملة ودنا...
تعرف تجربة «روشن»؟
اللي قالوا: احنا بندخل بس عشان نقول للمقاولين
ترى شغلكم مو بزين؟
إيه
أعتقد أن احنا جانا نفس الغضب ذا
أنه لا، ودنا نزل جهاز كويس
ونقول للناس: ترى غلط اللي قاعد تسويه
ودك تحط معيار كويس
معيار جيد
وغير ذلك، فيه تكلفة كبيرة في الشغل اللي تسوونه
خاصة نظام نقاط البيع
إذا عطيت لعميلك جهاز
وبعدين اكتشفت أنه غير مناسب
بعدين رجعه، وتعطيه جهاز ثاني
صح
وبعدين تروح تجرب من مورد وما مورد
فهذا يدخلك في دوامة
لا منتهية
يعني ما ألومك أنك تروح تصنع وخلاص
وترى مو كل الموردين شينين
بس أن كانت معاناة الصراحة
فقلنا: الأفضل أن نبدأ خط الإنتاج حقنا
حلو، فهذا تسوونه كله وتقدمونه للعميل
فهذا على مستوى الأجهزة
نتكلم عن البرمجيات
أيش الخدمات اللي تقدمها «رواء»؟
برنامج محاسبة اللي أطلقناه قبل كم شهر
وقبله كان إدارة المخزون للفرع
وإدارة المخزون مع القنوات الإلكترونية
كلها مربوطة بمكان واحد
والكاشير اللي هي نقطة البيع
الصفحة هذه البرنامج حق الكاشير اللي يبيع
الماسح هذا
حلو، أنا بركز على نقطتين من النقاط هذولي
عندك أول شيء إدارة المخزون
هذه أتصور كان فيها مشاكل كبيرة
صح
في طريقة إدارة المخزون
فأيش الاختلافات اللي لاحظتوها
في إدارة المخزون بين أنواع المحلات؟
طبعًا فيه ناس ما يعدون، ما عندهم مخزون ولا شيء
كم يمثلون نسبة لو بتخمنها بناء على تجربتكم؟
لا، ما أخمنها عندي أرقام رسمية
بحكم أن عندنا عدد بالوسط ممتاز
فعندنا أرقام رسمية
نقيسها على الاستخدام
أنا قصدي على حسب اطلاعكم في السوق
من اللي أصلًا يتابعون المخزون حقهم ومن ما يتابعون كنسبة؟
تقريبًا هو قرابة الـ 7% من التعاملات السنوية
بالتجزئة الآن يمر من خلال النظام حقنا
7%؟
إيه
من كل تعاملات التجزئة؟
في السعودية؟
بالضبط تقريبًا نتكلم على 9 مليار
شلون طلعت الرقم ذا؟
كم الـ «جي إم في» حقي؟
كم عدد العمليات اللي مرت من خلال النظام
مقارنة بحجم السوق؟
مقارنة إيه طبعًا
الرقم المعلن اللي هو تقريبًا 210 مليار
هذا التجزئة
انجاز ممتاز
إيه جيد
فبالتالي عندي مسحة مرة ممتازة
حتى أيش المضحك؟
لما أناظر أرقامي وأناظر الأرقام الحكومية
فيه إنعكاس مرة واضح
حلو، دام عندك عينة جيدة تقدر تقول نطلع نسب منها
كم نسبة العملاء اللي يديرون المخزون حقهم؟
والله أنه شيء محزن الصراحة، هو تقريبًا 30%
بس؟
إيه
والباقيين وشلون؟
يطبع ويدير والرازق بالسماء
غريبة!
هذا المبدأ
هل المشكلة تقنيًّا؟
أنهم ما يبغون يستخدمون طريقة إدارة المخزون التقنية؟
أنا أتصور كلهم عندهم جرد
وكلهم عندهم طريقة معينة لإدارة المخزون مو بقاعدين...
الإشكالية أنه بعد...
الآن طبعًا قاعدين ندرس الحالة هذه
لأنه بالمناسبة لنا هذه الحالة إذا حليناها
يكون أتوقع أن قيمة «رواء» بتصير قيمتها ما أدري
بس أحس أننا بنحل مشكلة كبيرة مرة بالتجزئة
فسؤالك عميق صراحة
لأن فعلًا هذه مشكلة حقيقية
بس أنا اسأل هل هذه مشكلة إدارة محل أو إدارة شركة
لها جزئين
وللا مشكلة تقنية في تبني تقنية
التكلفة، يقول أن أنا أجيب لي واحد بس يدخل المخزون علي
مرة مكلف علي
مكلف
إيه، كم بالشهر؟ أجيب بس واحد
كل ما جاء مخزون جديد بقعد أجرده وأدخله
وكل يوم جارد محلي وأنا ما عندي لا محل ولا محلين
حلو
فبالتالي بالنسبة له الشغلة ما هو بأفضل شيء
خاصة لو نتكلم عن بقالات مكلفة
إيه. بقالات، محلات ملابس
بالذات اللي عنده محلين ثلاثة
فما ينفع
أذكر مرة كان فيه كذا حوار عابر مع هندي في بقالة
كنت أسأله عن النظام اللي يستخدمه
فقلت له: أيش تستخدم؟
قال: استخدم بس هذا النظام عشان موضوع الضريبة
قلت له: طيب تستخدم إدارة مخزون؟
قال: ليش إدارة مخزون؟
أنا هنا فيه مخ إدارة مخزون
هذا بالضبط، عرفت؟
أنا أشوف إدارة مخزون
أنا معلوم شيء خلّص وللا شيء ما يخلص
هذا هو
ما شاء الله عليه كان
هذا احنا تعلمناه من تجار السوق مع الوقت
يقول: ترى لو دخلت عليه وقلت له إدارة...
أتذكر حتى بالبدايات
أنا و«عبدالله» كنا نلف ونبيع «خارج حدودنا» على قولتهم
نبيع بالشارع
ندور ونحاول نبيع البرنامج
فأتذكر «عبدالله» قال لي
أنا أعتقد أن احنا قللنا من شأن الورقة والقلم
يعني قد أيش أنها ممتازة
قد أيش أنها ممتازة كحل
قد أيش أن كفاءتها عالية ترى
يمكن الوضع مو...
وطبعًا هو طبيعي
فقلت له: لا إن شاء الله البرنامج اللي بنسويه
بيكون له قيمة أكبر
لكن بالأخير
إيه، إذا الورقة والقلم قاعدة تؤدي دورها
إيه بس بالنهاية احنا أثبتنا أن الورقة والقلم ما ينفع
بس الحل للناس الواعين، أيش يقول؟
يقول: لا، بالنسبة لي مهم خلاص وبجيب
أو أني أنا بدخل بنفسي
ثم مع الوقت يتكاسل
يكون متحمس بالبداية يدخل منتجات وشغل مرتب
ثم يتكاسل مع الوقت أو يأجل
ثم تبدأ أرقامه تخربط، ثم يصير ما يهتم
خلاص يمشي على الحسبة
بس كيف تتأكد أن الحل التقني متطابق
مع طريقة عمل المحل والتوقعات اللي عنده؟
لأن ممكن أنت تجيب حل رهيب
بس هو بالنسبة له يقول
يا أخي أنت صممت لي إياه بطريقة مختلفة
عن كيف أجرد أنا، وللا كيف أحط المخزون وللا كيف أطلع المخزون؟
لا، هذا طبعًا احنا ننزل له
وأول شيء عندنا طريقتين
احنا نشوف أيش البرامج العالمية
والشيء الثاني، ننزل السوق
ونخلي العملاء قبل ما ننزل الخاصية؛ هم يجربونها
ويقول: لا هذا بيخدمني
فأنا أتكلم عن الناس اللي بالفعل هو مقرر
أن يستخدم إدارة المخزون وأموره طيبة
هذا أنا أبدًا ما عندي مشكلة معه
أنا مشكلتي الكبيرة مع اللي أصلًا ما عنده نية
يستخدم إدارة المخزون أصلًا
متعب عليه وللا مكلف
ما يبي يسويها حتى بدون إنترنت
ما يبي، مو بفاضي
هذه هي اللي مشكلتي الكبيرة معه
هذولا اللي أنا ودي أتعامل معهم
بس الناس اللي بالفعل مقرر وكذا
ما عنده مشكلة مع إدارة المخزون حقي
طيب، السؤال اللي نتوقع أنه بيغير سوق التجزئة
وشلون أني أخلي الناس أول شيء تعرف
أو التجار يعرفون بأهمية إذا أنت تاجر تجزئة
كيف تدير المخزون بشكل مرة ممتاز
وتقاريرك تصير ممتازة وتتابع بشكل نظيف
بطريقة سهلة وغير مكلفة بالنسبة للتاجر
ولا هي يتثاقله وللا يشيل هم عليها
هذا هو السؤال أتوقع أنه...
سؤال مليون ريال، مليار
ففيه محاولات، عندنا محاولة الآن مشروع
نبي نجرب «آر آند دي» نستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي
طفرة الذكاء الاصطناعي
الذكاء الاصطناعي
أيش تسوي بالذكاء الاصطناعي؟
والله قاعدين نفكر بما أن الآن موضوع الفوترة الإلكترونية
فصار كل شيء الآن يجي مكتوب
يجي مطبوع من المورد
بدينا نشتغل بالتقنية أنه يصور الفاتورة
وتدخل مباشرة عنده بالجرد
هذا أنت قصدك المحل إذا استلم بضاعة
يصور الفاتورة حقتها
وتدخل على طول
على المخزون
إيه
عاد ذي يبي له شغل واجد أحس
والله أكيد أنه يبي له
بس أعتقد لو حلينا المشكلة هذه
نعتقد نرفعه لـ 65%
لأن كل مورد يجيب لك الفاتورة بشكل
لا، بس مكتوبة بالكمبيوتر الحين
إيه عشان الفوترة الإلكترونية
بالضبط، فهمت قصدي؟ فبيخدم
إيه فاهم، بس كيف تقرأ الوحدات؟
كيف تقرأ أيش الأصناف هذه
وتطابقها مع الأصناف اللي موجودة في النظام؟
صح
فيها تحدي
فيها تعلم كبير، ولازم يكون عندنا أصلًا صور كثيرة
عشان ندرب الآلة
لكن إن شاء الله التقنية هذه بنشتغل عليها إلين تنضج
أعتقد أن هو الحل، ما أدري إذا كان فيه حل ثاني ذكي
بس أعتقد أن هو الحل اللي بيرفع الجودة
وخاصة بالحلول التقنية
أنت ما ودك تسوي واجهة للمستخدم
وتقول له: تعال لو تستخدمها ترى بتلقى فائدة
لا، خلني أقدر استخدمها بسلاسة
ومن ضمن عملياتي اليومية
لا تقعد تتفلسف وتقول لي: هذه حتى بطريقة ذي
تعال لو تدخل البيانات كذا؛ بتضبط
وبعدين بيسحبون عليها
بس أنت الحين تطلع لهم أتصور تقارير كثيرة في النظام
فهذه ما تنعفس إذا قاعد يسحب على المخزون
يعني هذا اللي يتعبنا في الموضوع
ليش مثلًا مرة حريص أن التاجر يستخدم كل شيء بالنظام؟
ليش أنا حريص أن التاجر يستخدم المخزون؟
أول شيء عشان يستفيد هو من البرنامج
عشان يحس أن البرنامج قيمته به
والشيء الثاني عشان يستفيد من التقارير
ويصير فعلًا أنه لا، ترى أنا ما أخذته عشان مثلًا أطبع فاتورة
لا أنا ماخذه عشان أعرف
أيش اللي يتحرك؟ أيش اللي واقف؟
أنا خسران، أنا ربحان
تكاليفي أيش سالفتها؟
الوضع يسوى وللا ما يسوى معي
كل هذه التفاصيل مره مهمة
طيب أنا وشلون أكبر؟
طيب أيش أجيب؟
أيش المنتجات اللي أجيبها؟
شغل عشوائي! يلا امش وكذا
فودنا نغيّر السلوك هذا
والصراحة أننا نحاول نجتنب الخلل
طبعًا مؤسف فيه محلات كثيرة
الناس أتصور ما يتصورون عدد المحلات اللي في البلد
خاصة اللي عندهم محل واحد اللي ما يحسب شيء
اللي يجيك ما يدري كم ربحيته؟ ما يدري كم قاعد يصرف؟
يعني كذا اللي ماشي بالبركة
والله يضيق الصدر
ويطيح يمكن أحيانًا في ديون وفي قروض
اللي ماشي على عماه هذا
فهذولي اللي...
حتى أقول للزملاء
مرت علي أكثر من عميل
وحتى من دائرتي القريبة
يقول لي: لو لاحق على برنامجكم أيام أول
المحل الفلاني ما سكرته، والفلاني ما سكرته
ولا خسرت في المكان الفلاني
بعد ما يفهم القيمة
بس المشكلة هي مشكلة ثقافة بعد
يعني برنامجك مهما كان رهيب
بالنهاية إذا هو مو مقتنع بالموضوع ذا
ويقتنع أن الوضع سهالات
ما راح يستخدم من «رواء»
عشان كده نشتغل ونحاول بالمحتوى
نحاول بالبودكاستات
هذه بجيك عليها
بس عشان نختم جانب الخدمات اللي تقدمونها
بعد قلت محاسبة، إدارة مخزون
طبعًا فيه النظام حق الكاشير
أنا أتصور تسوون نفس الاختبارات
عشان تتأكدون أنه ما شيء مع المحل
بس موضوع المدفوعات دخلتوا فيها وللا؟
دخلنا موضوع المدفوعات
طبعًا دخلنا بالمدفوعات كتجربة
إلى الآن احنا بمرحلة التجربة للأمانة
وجالسين نحاول نتعلم بالسوق هذا
فيه أداء ممتاز، بس ما نتوقع أن المدفوعات
شيء بيكون مربح على المدى البعيد
بالذات مثلًا مع الأنظمة
تعرف أن مهما قدمت خدمة رهيبة وجميلة بالمدفوعات
بالأخير ما تقدر تدفع إلا ثمانية من الألف
بس إنها قد تساعدك في أنك تحكم
مثلًا استخدام الجهاز بشكل أفضل
بحيث أنه يستخدم الجهاز وبعدين يروح
المبرمج بدون ما يدخل الفاتورة
تروح على طول على جهاز المدفوعات
يعني يكون متحفز أكثر أنه لازم يدخل المبلغ بشكل دقيق
ما يسلّك بالفواتير على أساس أنه يجمع...
فعلًا هي بالنهاية...
طبعًا أنا كنت ضده، كنت ضد المدفوعات تمامًا
قاعد أشوف أن السوق تقريبًا كله 4 مليار أرباح المدفوعات
لشركات المدفوعات
بس بترفع دقة البيانات
يعني هو موضوع بشكل غير مباشر
أنا كنت أناظر من الناحية المالية كان غير مجدي
كل السوق 4 مليار وفيه ما أدري كم شركة تشتغل فيه
وكل الشركات ممتازة ورائدة
وفعلًا السوق متشبع جدًّا بقضية المدفوعات
ولو ببتكر وأبدع فيه وأسوي أشياء جميلة جدًّا
أساسًا الدعوة كلها 8 من الألف
وعلّي يا صراع العمالقة
فبالتالي ما هو مجدي من الناحية المالية
أنك تدخل في المدفوعات
إيه المدفوعات الحين صارت مثل الموية والكهرباء
بالضبط، فالابتكار وكذا ما هو مجدي الاستثمار فيه
أنك تبتكر بالعملية هذه ويكون جميل وكذا، ليش؟
لأنه محدود
أنظمة حكومية حادة عن قضية كم تأخذ من العميل
طيب خلانا أروح لأنه لا والله ما ودنا بالمدفوعات
ومن طلع المنتجات عندنا
واحد من الشباب أصر أنه كان عنده حالة معينة
مثل ما تفضلت
وعطاك قصة؟
عطاني قصة، عرفت سالفة «فورد» وهذه
وقال: لا أنه نبي نقدم تجربة مكتملة للعميل
وأن العميل يجي ياخذ منا الجهاز
ويجي ياخذ منا المدفوعات بعيدًا عن الربحية
لكنه بيخوض تجربة مكتملة مثل ما تفضلت مشهور
وفعلًا هذا اللي صار
يوم بدأ، بدينا على مضض
خلاص احنا بالنهاية نؤمن بالأرقام
وكان مجهز لي «كاشف الاختراق»
فخلاص احنا نؤمن بالأرقام
قلنا: بسم الله، استعنا بالله
خلاص بدينا؛ وغيّر مفهومي
بس أنت بديت من زاوية مختلفة شوي
اللي هم يسمونها أتوقع أنه رخصة الـ«إم إس بي » اختصار أيش؟
«مقدمي الخدمات التجارية» (Merchant Service Provider)
اللي هي رخصة أني أنا أقدم مدفوعات للعميل
خدمات المدفوعات للتجار
هذه أيش فرقها عن أنك تكون شركة مصرحة عند البنك المركزي؟
هذه فكرة عبقرية صارت من «ساما» ومن المدفوعات السعودية
أنه وشلون؟
بدل ما العالم تطلع رخص وتقدم وإلى آخره
يصير فيه واحد يبيع البنية التحتية حقت المدفوعات
وتصير فيه نسخة بسيطة
أن الشركات هذه تقدم خدمة المدفوعات
بدون ما تروح مع الرخص حقت «ساما»
لأن أغلب اللي يقدموا الرخص في النهاية
يا أنهم ما يستمرون، أو يصير فيه تحديات كبيرة
الحصول على رخصة تقديم خدمة المدفوعات صعبة جدًّا
الناس أحيانًا يستسهلونها
وسنوات تاخذ أحيانًا
في أغلب الحالات تأخذ سنوات
ممكن تاخذها بسرعة إذا أنت عارف أيش بتسوي بالضبط
بس نسبة كبيرة من الناس يمكن ما يقدرون يضبطونها
من ناحية تقنية ومن ناحية متطلبات
والتزام بالتشريعات والأمور ذي كلها
فهذه الرخصة الـ«إم إس بي» اسمها
أيش فايدتها؟
فهذه الفكرة منها أنه أنا خلاص ممكن آخذ بنية تحتية
من واحدة من الشركات، والشركة هذه أنا أعتمد عليها
وانطلق على طول في المدفوعات خلال أسبوعين
فهذه الشركة تكون مرخصة
مرخصة إيه
لتقديم خدمة المدفوعات
ومرت بالتجربة كله وكذا
بس أنا أصير الفوق
اللي فوق، اللي أقابل العميل
وأنا اللي أبيع المنتج حقي وإلى آخره
فأنت تصير في الواجهة
تقدم خدمة المدفوعات للشركة؟
بالضبط، وباسمي
ولكن أنا ما أجمع فلوس
التجميع يصير عن طريق البنوك
فأنت الحين تصير مصرح أنك تتعامل مع البنوك
لتقديم خدمة المدفوعات؟
بالضبط
حلو، فالفلوس تروح للبنك ما تجيك أنت؟
إيه طبعًا
لأنك ما أنت مصرح في النهاية
بالضبط
وأيش تستفيد؟
أنا أقدم أن هذه مدفوعات «رواء»
اللي هي جوّا برنامج «رواء»
وأنا أدير العملية كلها
ولكن بالنسبة للعميل هو يتعامل مع «رواء» كمدفوعات
لكن بالواقع أنا أخذت البنية التحتية الموجودة القوية
اللي طبعًا في السعودية من أفضل الدول في قضية المدفوعات
فبالتالي آخذ البنية التحتية الموجودة
وعلى طول أقدم الخدمة بشكل تقريبًا
أسبوعين أو ثلاث أسابيع أتذكر طلعنا فيها
فيه تحديات مع البنوك
لكن كخدمة طلعت فيها بسرعة
طيب أيش أستفيد أنا؟
أستفيد مثل ما قلنا بالبداية
أني أقدم تجربة مكتملة بالنسبة لعميلي
بس أنت أيش تحتاج عشان تقدر تطلع التصريح هذا؟
متطلبات على الحماية في قضية الواجهة حق المدفوعات حقنا
يعني ما أتذكر بالضبط أيش كانت المتطلبات
متطلبات بسيطة
لكنها سهلة وبسيطة
وتقدر تسويها بسرعة
إيه، أتوقع في أسبوعين أو ثلاث أسابيع خلاص
بحيث أنك تصير أنت الواجهة حق البنك
فهذا يدخلنا على موضوع نموذج العمل
أول شيء كيف آلية التسعير عندكم؟
وأيش مصادر الدخل عند «رواء» اليوم؟
نبدأ بعملية التسعير
من المدفوعات طبعًا
لا، اترك المدفوعات، اتكلم بشكل عام
الشيء الأساسي بالنسبة لنا الاشتراكات
فأنت عندك قيمة الجهاز اللي تبيعه بسعر التكلفة
وتبيع الاشتراكات
اشتراكات شلون سعرتها؟
طبعًا ناخذ التكلفة
وبعدين نشوف أيش ممكن العميل يقدر يدفع
أيش القيمة اللي احنا جالسين نقدمها للعميل
هل فعلًا أني أنا جالس أوفر على العميل فلوس؟
وأزيد من ربحية العميل وللا لا؟
بس شلون تقيس التكلفة؟
لا، قصدك...
أنت الآن تقول تحسب التكلفة وتضيف
بعدين تشوف العميل كم يدفع بالسوق بشكل عام
فتحسب حساب التكلفة كم؟ كيف تحسبها؟
رواتب الموظفين، رواتب المبيعات، الدعم الفني
المنتج نفسه نحن نبنيه
المهندسين اللي يبنون المنتج
مدراء المنتج
التكلفة هذه كاملة
أناظر كم يكلفني، ونقسمه على عدد سنوات معين
تمام
وأناظر خلال كم أنا بربح لو بعته مثلًا بالمبلغ الفلاني
فأنت مسوي لك نموذج إجمالي
إيه
اللي تشوفه على عدد سنوات معين؛ هذه التكلفة بتكون
فبعدين تطلع لك التكلفة الكم؟ الشهرية وللا السنوية؟
لو تبي بالساعة خلاص دام طلعتها
خلنا نقول السنوية
بدون ما نتعمق، أنت حسبت التكلفة حقها كم
فأنت هذه نقطة عندك
فيه نقطة ثانية كم مستعدين العملاء يدفعون بالسوق
بالضبط
بس نكبة لو طلع أقل من التكلفة
هذا كارثة طبعًا
وكثير من الشركات تموت هنا أصلًا
أو العكس، أو أنك مثلًا تسعر أقل من اللي يقدر يدفعه العميل
فتخسر
فتخسر هامش الربح
لكن هو تحدي صراحة كبير مرة
اللي احنا سويناه أنه افترضنا الأسوأ
وأن العميل مثلًا ما يقدر يدفع شيء
وبدينا من سعر مرة قليل
أقل من التكلفة وللا؟
في البداية كان أقل من التكلفة
حلو، فأنت عندك دخل من الاشتراكات
إيه
الأجهزة بسعر التكلفة تقول
المدفوعات إيه
والمدفوعات أيضًا تأخذ منها نسبة بسيطة جدًّا
وأيش فيه بعد؟
تقريبًا هذه هي
هذه الأشياء الأساسية اللي تشتغلون فيها
إيه هذه الثلاثة
القطاعات اللي تستهدفونها أيش هي؟
الأساسية، عندنا أربعة عشر قطاع أساسي
بس من أبرز القطاعات هذه
بقالات، ملابس، الكماليات، محلات الورود والعسل
يعني اللي عندها مخزون تقريبًا
تقريبًا أي قطاع في التجزئة عنده مخزون
نخدمه بشكل ممتاز ومثالي
أتصور أسوأها البقالات
راح تتفاجأ أن أفضل عميل نخدمه البقالات
معقولة؟
إيه
طبعًا نتكلم عن القطاع هذا
أنت عندك بقالة، ميني ماركت، سوبر ماركت
فيه مجموعة عملاء، فهل تقصدهم كلهم؟ وللا أنت تقصد؟
أفضل عميل عندنا اللي عنده تقريبًا
بين ثلاث إلى ثمان فتحات
حلو، مو بالواحد اللي قد يكون تستر
إيه، لا هذا ما يبينا
غالي عليه البرنامج ولا يسوى معه
هو يبي شيء بس عشان يلتزم عليه
التستر أصلًا ما تتخيل قد أيش احنا أعداء
إيه، لأن أنت بتكشف اللي عنده
أنا بكشف اللي عنده
وأساسًا اللي يبغى البرنامج يبحث عن قيمة
حقين التستر ما يبحث عن قيمة
يبي كل شيء هو اللي يحاسب نفسه
ولا يبحث عن برنامج عشان يكبّر النشاط حقه
لا، هو طموحه البقالة
اللي هو ماخذه من الشخص اللي يدفع له
ولا عنده طموح أن يكبر وكذا، فبالتالي...
فأنت تشوف من القطاع هذا
أغلب عملائكم اللي عندهم فرعين أو ثلاثة أو أكثر
لأنه يبدأ يدخل في حوسة
فرع بس يكون كبير أو فرعين أو ثلاثة
بس يبدأ من فرع، اثنين، ثلاثة
بس تكون كبار ما تكون صغيرة
فهذا العميل اللي عادةً حتى لو عنده فرع واحد
اللي يوصل نقطة يحتاج يدير مخزون ويأمن الوضع
يبي له شغل، يبي له برنامج زين
الصغار هذولي ما ...؟
إيه لا، المايكرو لا «رواء» ما يخدمهم
خدمات التسويق عندكم أيش هي؟
نستخدم كل شيء يطري على بالك
ابتداءً من الإعلانات الرقمية
إيه، تبي الله يطول بعمرك
الإعلانات الرقمية؟
إيه، تبي تويتر، تيك توك، لينكدإن، إنستقرام
أي شيء يقول فيه ناس نعلن به
بس حسب تجربتكم، أيش أكثر شيء يناسب
أو وين أكثر تواجد لعميل؟
اللي هي شركات «خدمة قطاع الأعمال»
من تجربتنا راح تتفاجأ أن سناب شات تصدق؟
معقولة؟
إيه، سناب شات وطبعًا بحث قوقل وإعلانات قوقل
إعلانات قوقل حق البحث هذه
هذه أفضل قناتين عندنا
بعدين يروح يدور نظام متوافق مع الزكاة مثلًا
بالضبط، وللا مثلًا نظام إدارة مخزون
وللا نظام كاشير وللا نظام محاسبي
فهذا أفضل قناة عندنا
الثانية أو يجي معها قريب منا مرة سناب شات
وصدمة سناب شات
وعندكم برضه محتواكم الخاص
مسوّي بودكاست
إيه، بودكاست ولا شيء
أيش المسكة مسوّي بودكاست؟
والله أنا قلت لك أي شيء ممكن يفيد نجربه
كنت تقابل تجار
بس البودكاست كان المقصد منه محتوى جيد للتجار التجزئة
نحاول وأن ودنا...
تعرف قضية المخزون وكيف الناس تستفيد
وشلون يفهمون أهمية المخزون وكذا
لأن إذا هو فاهم أهمية المخزون
راح يبدأ يستخدم النظام بشكل جيد
وبالتالي راح ياخذ مني خدمات بشكل...
أنا أشوف شركات كثير تسوي موضوع
أنها تسوي مدونة تثقيفية
عنده مدونة إيه
أحد الضيوف مثلًا عنده سناب شات شخصي
هو يثقّف فيه
أصلًا ما قد شفت أحد مسوي بودكاست صراحة
أنتم و «زد» أتوقع اللي مسوين بودكاست؟
إيه
فكيف تجربة البودكاست شفتوها؟
والله أشوفها ناجحة
تخيل جلسنا ثلاث سنوات نكتب محتوى
وما كان يجيب نتيجة
واستمرينا بالاستثمار فيه
كنا متوقعين أن يومًا ما بيضبط معنا المحتوى
اليوم جالسين نبيع مبالغ ممتازة من خلال المحتوى
العملاء اللي يدخلون على المدونات حقتنا ويشترون
يعني مو بس غطى التكلفة، لا بدينا نربح
والبودكاست تحديدًا جاب لكم عميل؟
طبعًا البودكاست الصدمة كانت أكبر
كانت التوقعات مرة منخفضة
اكتشفت أن فيه ناس كثير ما عرفوا «رواء» إلا من خلال البودكاست
اللي يدخل على البودكاست اليوم
بيشوف المشاهدات طبعًا مقارنة ببرامج ثانية
بيشوفها قليلة
إيه فيه 20 ألف، فيه 10 ألف، فيه 2000
إيه، بس في السياق حقكم؛ أتصور تعتبر عالية
بالضبط
لأنه تحول إلى مبيعات
بالضبط لأنها مخصصة
والمقصد من البودكاست إطلاقًا ما كان مبيعات
كان ودنا أن التجار يفهمون أهمية المخزون
يفهم الأشياء البسيطة
التكتيكات اللي بالتسويق
تحاول يثقفهم أكثر
بالضبط، ودنا أننا نخلق مثل المجتمع
لتجار التجزئة اللي عندهم فروع
جربتوا الإعلان مع المشاهير وللا؟
إيه، جربنا كثير الإعلان مع المشاهير
يضبط بمعاملات الشركات استهداف الشركات؟
والله شوف الشباب زعلانين علينا كثير
ليش؟
بعض الصناديق يجي يقول لك أيش قاعد تسوي؟
الصناديق الاستثمارية
ليش تعلن مع المشاهير؟
إيه، أنت لا تفقه
بالعكس أنا ما عندي مشكلة
دائم نقول لهم: بالعكس احنا ما عندي مشكلة
ناظروا أرقامنا
لأن غريب صراحة أنك تروح تعلن عند مشاهير
وأغلب اللي يتابعونهم أفراد
تبي أدخل معك بموضوع رياضي؟
تبي نحسب أنا وياك بورقة وقلم؟
أنا بحسب وياك بورقة وقلم
كم الآن اليوم...
احنا بدينا نعلن مع المشاهير بطريقة التفكير هذه
كم اليوم القوة العاملة بالسعودية؟
كم عدد السعوديين اللي يشتغلون اليوم بالقطاع الحكومي والخاص؟
4 مليون
عدد السجلات التجارية 1.4 مليون
وفيه ناس معهم شركاء ولا مكتوب أساميهم بعد
بس نتوقع أنه لا يقل عن مليونين
يا أنه شريك في القطاع
أو أنه يملك بشكل مباشر بالقطاع
فتخيل أن نصف القوة العاملة
فئة بالنسبة لنا محتملة أو عميل محتمل
فهي تعتبر سوق كبير جدًّا
يمكن تنظر لها من زاوية كفاءة التسويق
أنك أنت كأنك قاعد ترمي شبك على مجموعة كبيرة
وتقول يا رب
وتقول يا رب، أن فيه أحد سمكة أو سمكتين تطلع فيه
بس أنت خسران بالأخير
عكس أنك تروح مكان عارف مليان سمك، تقول برمي
طبعًا احنا ندور هذا المكان المليان سمك
تكفى أن كانك تعرفه علمنا
فيه برنامج سوالف بيزنس صح؟
إيه، صح لكنه
وأنا جايبك عشان أبيعك، اسلم
لكن لو أقولك احنا وشلون بدينا وبعدين وشلون صرنا
بتعرف أن ترى احنا أي مكان فيه مليان سمك؛ ترى هذا حلبناه
خلنا بعيدين عن سالفة السمك
احنا الحين قلنا خلاص أنتم جربتوا كل قنوات التسويق
المشاهير، ودك كم المشاهير اشترى عليه
لأن هذا ترى أكثر موضوع انسأل عنه
حلو، اسلم، طيب
المشاهير أيش طريقة حسبتي فيه؟
إذا كان يجيب لي، هذا قاعدة بـ«الساس»
«الساس» اللي هو تقديم البرمجيات كخدمة
بالضبط، هذا قاعدة عامة
إذا كان عائد الإعلان واحد فأكثر؛ أمورك طيبة
احنا عائد المشاهير عندنا
يوليو مثلا كان تقريبًا 1.6 تقريبًا
أيش قصدك 1.6؟
العائد الاستثماري، أنه غطى قيمته
وجاب لي تقريبًا 50-60% زيادة على قيمة الإعلان
فأنت تحسب الحين كم أدفع للمشهور
إلى المشاهير وكم جاك
كم أدفع للمشاهير أو لأحد المشاهير
عشان ما نقول مشهور
لأحد المشاهير دفعت له مثلًا 10 ألاف
كم جاتني مبيعات من هذه الـ 10 ألاف؟
صح
طيب طبيعي ما راح تجيك مبيعات بس 10 ألاف
أكيد أنها بتكون أضعاف اللي أعلنت
لا، أضعاف
هو بس يبيع لك كم؟
لو يبيع لك أربعة أنت ضاعفت
فما أحس أنها منطقية
المشروع حقنا طريقة عملنا كشركة برمجيات
إذا جاب لك أكثر من واحد؛ أمورك طيبة
ليش؟ لأن العميل أنا عندي يقعد خمس إلى ست سنوات
متوسط بقاء العميل عندي
اللي يسمونها حياة العميل
عندي خمس سنوات إلى ست سنوات
إيه هي اللي يسمونها «إل تي في»
«قيمة عمر العميل» (Lifetime Value)
بالضبط
فبالتالي الحسبة إذا كانوا من أول مرة جاب لي أكثر من واحد
معناته أنه أصلًا جاب لي ستة
لأن حقي المتوسط رياضيًا ستة
تمام، فأنت إذا صرفت مبلغ معين على أحد المشاهير
وجاب لك أكثر من واحد
طالما يجيب لك أكثر من واحد
فمعناته يجيب لي أقل شيء ستة
طيب يوليو كان 1.6
معناته أحسب عاد 1.6 ضرب
من وين طلعت موضوع
أنه يقعد معك ست سنوات على الأقل؟
طبعًا هي قاعدة رياضية معروفة
اللي هي تأخذ بالاعتبار عدد العملاء اللي يشتركون الجدد
وتناظر عدد الانسحابات
كم اللي ما يجددون
بالضبط، كم اللي ما يجددون
فتعرف خلال سنة ما يجددون ترى هذا
معناته خذ على الخمس أو ست سنوات
وخلال كم كل العملاء ذولا بيطلعون
يعني كلما قضيتوا سنوات أكثر
يصير عندكم متوسط لعدد الانسحابات؟
لا، كل ما قل عدد الانسحابات عندي
معناته أن مدة بقاء العميل عندي أعلى
لا فاهم عليك، بس أنا قصدي مثلًا
خلنا نقول هذه أول سنة لكم
عندكم عشرين عميل ما جددوا
اللي هي 20% انسحبوا
تقدر تبني عليها توقع للخمس سنوات الجاية
بس ما راح تكون بدقة لرقم بعد السنة الثانية
بالضبط
في السنة الثانية تكتشف أنها ثمانية عشر
تقول تمام، الحين أكون أكثر ثقة في الرقم
بالضبط
في السنة الثالثة تكتشف أنه خمسة عشر
تقول فيه ترند الحين، لأنهم قاعدين ينكمشون
فأنا أصير متفائل في التوقعات حقي
جدًّا في قضية كم يقعد العميل
«عبدالله» بيحبني على الكلام ذا
إيه بالعكس
فأنت تبرر الاستثمار بهذه الطريقة
أنه حسبت المتوسط كم يقعد معاك العميل
فأنت الحين روّجت للعملاء
ووصلت لعميلي إيه
وتتبع نفس الطريقة ونفس الحسبة وكذا
بس الرقمي هو نفسه
طيب جاك العميل الآن، أيش يواجه أول شيء؟
جاء العميل سجّل عندنا بالصفحة
يدخل في الموقع
إيه أو دق، لكن خل نقول مثلًا سجّل بالصفحة
على طول ينزل عندي بطريقة مؤتمتة
ينزل عندي
طلب جديد
عميل مهتم
يسمونه «ليد»
إيه «ليد»
تجي مكالمة، عندنا فريق ما قبل المبيعات
يتأكدون أن هذا عميل حقيقي وعنده نشاط تجاري
وأربع أسئلة أساسية
تقريبًا المكالمة تأخذ دقيقة أو دقيقة ونصف
يجيكم عملاء غير حقيقيين؟
كثير، وظائف، أقساط
طبيعي
فهي البداية عدد كبير من العملاء المحتملين
اللي أغلبهم ما يطلعون أصلًا
قاعدين نحسن الرقم هذا
وصلنا إلى مرحلة المتوسط العالمي
تقريبًا 64% يكونوا عملاء حقيقيين
اللي يسمونهم «إس كيو إل»
أيش ممكن تسأل العميل عشان تتأكد أنه عميل حقيقي وللا؟
بالأسئلة، أسأله هل عندك نشاط تجاري أو لا؟
كم عندك فرع؟
أيش نوع نشاطك التجاري؟
أسأل أسئلة إذا ما جاوبه
فهو معناته أنه ماهو بعميل
وإذا جاوبه أيش يصير؟
أودّيه للمبيعات الآن
أكتب المعلومات هذه عنه المبدئية
وأجهز موظف المبيعات عشان يدخل معه بالمكالمة
فيبدأ عاد موظف المبيعات يسأله أكثر
أيش النقاط الألم عندك؟
طيب ليش تبغى البرنامج؟
طيب أيش ممكن يحل بالنسبة لك؟
وكل التفاصيل هذه
يبدأ عاد يطبخ البرنامج على حسب احتياج العميل
فهل تهيئون البرنامج له قبل ما تعطونه إياه؟
إيه لازم
تحطون له كل الأغراض حقته وكل شيء؟
عند النشاط عندنا مثلًا حسابات لكل نشاط
يكون أيش اللي مجهز فيها؟
مجهز فيها مثلًا أنت عندك بقالة
عندي حساب فيه 50 ألف منتج
جاهز
جاهز حق البقالة وصور البقالة وكل شيء متكامل
صور المنتجات قصدك والأشياء هذه
بس محل ملابس ما؟
لا، أوريه محلات ملابس مثله
بس مو بلازم يصير مثلًا نفس منتجاته
بس أقول مثلًا ملابس تعال
هذا محل ملابس كذا يشتغل
فأيش تجهز له؟
أجهز له صور من النت
أجيب له صور من النت حق ملابس
مثلًا من «أمازون» وللا من هذه المواقع
وأصف له صور ملابس
وأنزل له منتجات ملابس، مثلًا عدده 200 أو 300
لأن فيه أشياء مشتركة تكون بينهم؟
إيه، لأنهم بالغالب خلاص
إذا هو معنا ملابس، وهذاك محل ملابس
بيصيرون نفس بعض بالضبط نفس المشروع
بس المنتجات تختلف مفروض
هذا عنده تيشرت أزرق
لحظة، أنت قصدك...
لا، أنا عشان بس أشرح له
تمام، أنت تشرح له الحين بس كيف يستخدم النظام وذا
إيه أنا أشرح له عشان بس أقوله أيش رأيك يعني اشتر
ثم لو اشترى، بفترض أنه اشترى
أنت قصدك تشرح له شلون يستخدم النظام
في سياق محل ملابس
أحسنت
وللا في سياق محل بقالة
بالضبط
هذا عملية البيع تعرض له عشان يشتري
وافق، عندي كم متوسط الصفقة
خلنا نقول مثلًا بعطيك رقم اعتباطي خمسة أيام
لكل عميل
إيه لكل عميل
بعد خمسة أيام أول ما يوقع
طبعًا كل العمليات العمليات مؤتمتة
يعني أنه يروح من قسم لقسم
يطلع من ما قبل المبيعات ويروح لهذا مؤتمت
ثم قفّل العميل بعد ما يوصل مبيعات قفّل
يوديه أنه قفّل
الشباب بالدعم الفني على طول يستلمونه
لا شرى هو أول مع موظف المبيعات
هو حوّل مقدم كل المبلغ؟
مقدم حنّا، ما يتحول للتدريب إلا وهو مقدم
أول ما يتحول على طول يجي موظف الدعم الفني يستلمه
إلين يطبع خمسين فاتورة وهكذا
أوه إلين يطبع خمسين فاتورة
إيه
يعني يكون معاه واحد من حقين الدعم الفني
فعلًا إيه
يعني كل موظف دعم فني عندك
مسؤول عن عدد معين من العملاء
صح
يتأكد أنهم يتجاوزون خمسين فاتورة
مرحلة معينة
عشان كذا عندنا نسبة الانسحاب مره منخفض
اللي هو نسبة الانسحاب
بالضبط نسبة انسحاب العملاء عندنا منخفضة
بس أيش يسوي له؟
هو شاف مثلًا وطبع ثلاث فوتير ووقّف
ينشب له
بكل بساطة
أصلًا لأن عمولة الدعم الفني قائم أنه يطبع خمسين فاتورة
فالدعم الفني محفز جدًّا أن...
أن العملاء فعليًّا يخلصون خمسين فاتورة
طريقتنا احنا في الدعم الفني
ترى حتى الشباب اللي اللي عقبه
اللي هو خلاص صار الآن ناشط وكذا
ثم جاء يسأل أسئلة
الشباب اللي يردون على الاستفسارات
هذولا على كل رسالة يرد عليها
يأخذ عليها نسبة، يأخذ عليها فلوس
ما تحس هذه يمكن تحفز أن يكون فيه عملاء وهميين يدفدفون
لا طبعًا، هي مرة محسوبة من أكثر من ناحية
مثلًا أنه لازم العميل يكون طابع خمسين فاتورة
لازم العميل يكون دافع
لازم العميل يكون نشط
بس يجي واحد من موظفين خدمة العملاء
يكلم واحد من أخوياه من حقين «رواء»
يقول ارسلي استفسارات بالله
لا طبعًا ما يقدر لأنه هل هو مشترك وللا صديقه ذا؟
إيه مشترك
تمام بيسوي مرة مرتين
بس غالبًا بيروح الاستفسار واحد ثاني ما راح يقدر
خلنا نقول بيسوي مرة مرتين
إذا شفنا العميل أصلًا عنده استفسارات كثير
نرجع له ونقول أيش السالفة تعال
هذه نقطة
والنقطة الثانية أصلًا مؤتمت قضية هذا يروح لوين
الإسناد
إيه، قضية الإسناد هذه أصلًا مؤتمتة
فنسبة أنك تضمن أن التذكرة هذه بتجيك مرة منخفضة
طيب الآن أنا حق الدعم الفني وصلتك فوق الخمسين فاتورة
أيش يصير فيك بعدين؟
خلاص الآن أحولك على حقين نجاح التجار يسمونه
أني أتابع معك كل فترة
كل ثلاثة أو أربعة أو خمسة شهور
أني أتأكد أنه بس ما وقفت استخدام النظام
أول ما يوقف؛ يرجع يتصل علي مرة ثانية
تمام، بس خلال هذا الوقت
ما في طريقة تتأكد أنه يستخدم صح؟
لا، يستخدمه صح
هذولا حق مدراء المنتج هم اللي يتابعون
أنه من هم الناس اللي مثلًا البقالات وما يستخدم مخزون؟
طلعهم على جنب، خلنا نكلمهم ونشوف سالفتهم
فنتواصل معهم ونحاول نحفزهم
أنهم يستخدموا النظام بشكل سليم
فمدراء المنتج يراقبون استخدام العملاء
بحيث أنهم يطورون المنتجات
يا أما بتسهيل خصائص معينة
التجربة، بالضبط يضيف خصائص
وأتصور يزورون العملاء كثير
طبعًا، ينزلون يبيعون بأنفسهم
فيه شركات يوظفون مدراء منتجات
مدراء المنتجات هذولي ما يحتكون مع العملاء نهائيًّا لسببٍ ما
طبعًا هذه من الكوارث
وهذه أصلًا من نضج السوق عندنا
أن السوق مو بناضج أن يكون عندنا
مدراء المنتجات عالميًّا أصلًا هم عددهم قليل
في السعودية هنا رواتبهم مبالغ فيها صراحة
وبالسعودية منخفض بشكل أكبر بكثير
والسبب لأنه ترى عندنا احنا شركات تقنية
مثل «علم» و«ثقة»
بس أيش المشكلة؟
أنك لما تطلع برنامج «أبشر»
غصبًا عليه يستخدم «أبشر»
لا، هو أنا أعتقد...
مع أنه يضيف للبرنامج
بس أنا أقولك أن مدير المنتج مو محفز
أنه لازم يصنع تجربة خرافية ومثالية
لأنه ترى لو ما سوى كذا؛ ترى ما راح يستخدم الخاصية حقته
أنا قناعة شخصية ما يطلع مدير منتج جيد
إلا إذا اشتغل في شركة عندها منافسين
صح
أما يشتغل في شركة ما عندها منافس
قد يكون مدير مشروع ممتاز مرة
بس لا يسمى مدير منتج
صح
مدير منتج يجي واحد يعرف يتفاعل مع السوق
يعرف كيف يحط أشياء تخليك تتفوق على المنافس
أما إذا هي خدمة مثلًا مجبورين الناس يستخدمونها
مدير مشروع هذا ليس مدير منتج
فعلًا
هو هدفه فقط أنه يتأكد أن المشروع يطلع بسرعة
صح
لكن يسموه مدير منتج لسببٍ ما
أتفق معك 100%
لأن الحين السوق يحاول يواكب الموضوع هذا
يشوف أن الناس مثلًا الشباب متحمسين يصيرون مدراء منتجات
فبعض الشركات تسمي مدير المشروع مدير منتج
عشان يغرونهم في التوظيف وكذا
أوه! لا طبعًا هو فيه إدارة المنتجات وإدارة المشاريع التقنية
لها مسارين مختلفة من ناحية مهنية
ولكن الكارثة أن تلقى واحد مثلًا توّه متخرج بالجامعة
يقول أبغى أصير مدير منتج
أو مسماه مدير منتج
في العالم ذي ما تصير
ما في مدير منتج عنده أقل من سنتين أو ثلاث سنين خبرة
صعبة، أنا شخصيًّا إذا جيت أوظف مدير منتج
أشوف واحد لازم يكون عنده تدريب في الشركات خلال دراسته
يعني يكون إذا بوظفه وتوّه خريج جديد
وطازج وتوظفه وتخليه مدير منتج على طول
ما يكون مدير، يكون مساعد مدير منتج، يتعلم إلين ما...
الطريقة اللي احنا نسويها، ويمكن تستفيد منه
نسوي له دوران
نخليه يشتغل بأشياء مالها علاقة بالتقنية
ونخليه يدخل داخل المشروع
مثلًا يشتغل تسويق سنة
وللا يشتغل مبيعات وللا دعم فني
وللا أي شيء ثم نجيبه
لا ممتازة مرة ذي
على الأقل تخليه يدور على الأقسام اللي بيحتك معها
أو أن واحد رهيب اخترق الأقسام
تجيبه وتخليه مدير منتج أفضل
أنا ما ودي نقلب الموضوع عن إدارة المنتجات
وفيه موضوع ثاني بغطيه معك
اللي هو قياس الأداء
كان فيه نقاش قبل الحلقة بيننا ما دخلنا في تفاصيله
اللي هو أنت تقول تقييس أداء كل موظف في الشركة
أيش يسوي بالضبط
موضوع قياس الأداء شلون تسوونه؟
احنا ما ودنا نصير قاسيين
ولكن بشكل عام طريقة قياس الأداء عندنا
إدعاء كبير
طريقتنا احنا نتعامل بطريقة قياس الأداء بشكل مرة مختلف
أن عندنا «أوه كي آرز» وعندنا مؤشرات الأداء
وتنزل، واحنا كشركة هذه أهدافنا
نبدأ بالاستراتيجية ثم نبدأ أنها تصير أهداف
ثم هذه الأهداف تنزل إلى الأقسام
ثم الأقسام ينزلونها بشكل ربعي على الموظفين
طريقة الـ «أوه كي آرز» «Objective Key Result»
اللي هي عندك هدف تحته...
وشلون نترجمها
الـ «الأهداف المرحلية» (Sub Key Result) قصدك؟
لا، الهدف هذا
«الغاية» (Objective)
و«الأهداف المرحلية» (Sub Key Result)
فيه اللي عندك الهدف وبعدين
و«النتاج الرئيسية» هي الأشياء اللي لازم تحققها
عشان تحقق الهدف
بعدين كل واحدة من هذولي تنقسم
بالضبط
وتنزل على إلى أن تنزل على الفريق
إلى ما تنزل للموظفين
فبالتالي كذا نسويها احنا
وعندنا برنامج يتابع
أيش تستخدمون؟
نسوّق للبرنامج؟
عادي
اسمه «بروفيت دوت إيه أوه»
بروفيت؟
«بروفيت دوت كو» اسم برنامج «بروفيت دوت كو»
فيه برنامج ثاني بعد اسمه «ليب سم»
هذه خيارات ثانية
فيه برامج كثير لقياس الأداء اللي موضوع الـ «أوه كي آرز»
ولكن الصعوبة فيه أن لازم واحد متفرغ
يتابع الأشياء هذه ويتأكد أنه تصير
يصير مثلًا مدير مشاريع
أو مثلًا يكون تابع الموارد البشرية
بحيث أنه يتأكد أن كل الأقسام شغالة بطريقة معينة
وباتجاه اللي أنت تبي الشركة تصير عليه
كلهم يدخلون أهدافهم
وكلهم بعدين يراجعونها
إيه
قبل ما نطلع عن موضوع التسويق والمبيعات والأداء والأمور هذه
أيش سالفة الفرع؟
فتحتوا فرع في حراج الكمبيوتر
من أشطح ما يكون
هذه الأشياء الغريبة اللي نسويها بالتسويق
ولكن الحرب على موضوع الفرع أكثر مما توقعت
من اللي حاربني حاربكم، المستثمرين يعني
بالضبط عرفت
وشركة تقنية
يجون يقولون: للدرجة دي زادت فلوسنا عليكم
تروحون تفتحون فروع!
اللي فهمته أنك رحت فتحت
عند الشركات التقليدية حقت الكاشير
أيش السبب؟
لها فكرة هي، الفكرة أن وشلون أوصل عميلي
أغلب عملائنا كانوا أعمارهم ما بين 28 و 38 سنة
في طبيعة الحال أغلب التجار أعمارهم أكثر
بين 40 و 55 أو أكثر
ولكن لأن القنوات التسويقية
اللي أنا جالس أستخدمها اليوم وأتواجد فيها
أكثر شيء أحصله من الناس هذولا
فقلنا طيب وشلون؟
ودنا نوصل للفئة اللي مثلًا صعب توصل لها عن طريق سناب شات
وللا صعب توصل لها عن طريق مثلًا لينكد إن
فأيش الحل؟
خضنا تجارب كثيرة تويتر
نزلنا بالشوارع، سوينا مثلًا موضوع اللي هو لوحات الشوارع
سوينا تفاصيل كثيرة نبي نوصل للفئة
اللي نعتقد أنه أكثر بكثير من الفئة الأصغر
يعني أنا مستغرب أنه إلى الحين فيه ناس يروحوا حراج الكمبيوتر
هذا اللي صدمنا
اللي في الرياض
احنا صرنا نسأل العملاء الكبار
وشلون؟ وأيش ممكن تسوي؟
اكتشفنا أنه ما زال فيه اعتمادية على حراج الكمبيوتر
فقلنا تدري خلنا نخوض التجربة
نستخدمه كتسويق يكون مكان بارز وجيد
على طريق «ريّا» ويجوز أنه شارع رئيسي
ونستخدمه مسرح لنا، أي منتجات جديدة نحط
يكون شكل المكان زين
فنستخدمه «حج وقضاء حاجة» على قولتهم
وضبطت الصراحة
كم شهر لكم الحين؟
الآن تقريبًا من «الافتتاح الهادئ»
بدينا تقريبًا من شهر مايو الماضي
تقريبًا كم؟
أربعة أو خمسة شهور تقريبًا
جاب لكم نوعية عملاء مختلفة عن اللي عندكم؟
جدًّا، جاب لنا نوعية من العملاء
اللي يدخل يدفع على طول
ما فيه سالفة من خمسة أو ستة أو سبعة أيام
أيش اختلافه عن العملاء اللي يجون عن طريق النت؟
كبار بالغالب، كبار بالسن
ويالله يمكن يستخدم «أبشر»
بس أن عنده نشاط ممتاز وناجح
يبي جهاز يلمسه
يبي جهاز يشوفه ويتأكد منه
ماهو جاي معه اثنين محاسبين وللا ثلاثة محاسبين
ويبي يناظر أيش السالفة، يبي يفهم يعني
هذه النقطة ذكرها ضيف ثاني بالموسم غريبة صراحة
طبعًا ماهي قاعدة
بس الشركات تفضل أن تروح تعاين بضاعتك
وتشوفها قبل ما تتعاقد معك
ما تبي أحد يكون بس عبر الإنترنت
هذه وحدة من الأسباب
قلنا خلنا نجرب وندخل على فئة جديدة
فنزلنا فيها
وإلين اليوم الفرع مغطى تكاليفه بالتأكيد
بس إن شاء الله على نهاية الستة شهور هذه
يعني نهاية السنة إن شاء الله
نبي نسوي إعادة تقييم مرة ثانية
ونتأكد هل هو يستحق أن احنا نكبر ونفتح فروع
وللا خلاص نكتفي بالفرع هذا
أيش الشراكات اللي بنيتوها
على أساس تقدرون تحسنون الخدمات اللي تقدمونها
مثل النت على سبيل المثال
سواءً التوزيع أو الوصول لعملاء جدد
لو تعطيني بس تصور على الشراكات اللي سويتوها
لأن مشروع مثل مشروعكم مستحيل ينجح لحاله
صح
لازم يبني شراكة مع مجموعة من الشركات
في المنطقة بشكل عام
فأيش الشراكات الأساسية اللي عندكم الحين؟
من خلال المنصة حقتنا طبعًا
شركاء تقنيين من خلال المنصة
«زد» و«سلة» و«قيود» كبرنامج محاسبي
هذولا شركاء الربط؟
اللي هم يا برامج محاسبية أو منصات تجارة إلكترونية
بالضبط
حلو، وغير الربط هذولي من فيه؟
فيه طبعًا «إس تي سي»
يقدمون لكم النت وللا؟
إيه، ناخذ منهم النت وناخذ منهم الأجهزة
فالجهاز أنا كعميل لو اشتريته يجي معه نت؟
اليوم لا، لازم تطلب النت
وأعطيك فوقه النت
وهذه تربح منها وللا؟
ناخذ عليها عمولة بسيطة مرة، لا تذكر
فهذه شراكة مع «إس تي سي»
إيه، وأيضًا شراكة مع «إس تي سي» في قضية الأجهزة
أجهزة أيش؟
هذه الأجهزة المحمولة باليد وحتى أجهزة الكاشير
تبي تكون عن طريق «إس تي سي» أيضًا
أجل أيش تصنعون أنتم؟
صار عندنا خط إنتاج
خط الإنتاج هذا صارت «إس تي سي» تأخذ هذه الأجهزة
وفق المعايير اللي هم يبغونها
صارت معاييرنا ومعاييرهم
خل نقول صار فيه شوي تقارب فيها
فبالتالي صاروا يشترون من خط الإنتاج حقنا
وهم يبيعونه للسوق
بالإضافة إلى أنا عميلي أقول له
روح وخذ من «إس تي سي»
خذ الجهاز
أيش يفيدك هذا الشيء فيه؟
يفيدني أن التوصيل
البنية التحتية حق «إس تي سي» مرة ممتازة ما شاء الله
فالتوصيل سريع، الخدمة مثالية
العميل عنده مشكلة بالجهاز؛ الاستبدال مرة سريع
فأقدم خدمة عظيمة لعميلي
فأنت اليوم تضمن أن عندك موزع في المنطقة
اللي هو «إس تي سي»
هو يستفيد من وفرة جهاز
يكون عنده مخزون جهاز ممتاز بتكلفة قليلة
بالضبط
فهو يعطيها لعملاء «رواء» وعملاء غير «رواء»
أي أحد ثاني هو يوزعها لهم
وأنت تستفيد من أن فيه أحد يمسك عنك التوزيع
فإذا أنا الحين عميل طلبت «رواء»
بيجيني من «إس تي سي» التوصيل؟
بالضبط
فهم شالوا عنك هم التوصيل والاستلام والأمور ذي كلها
بالضبط، فبالتالي هذه هي تجربة
اللي أنا أعتبرها من التجارب المميزة
بالإضافة إلى أنه نزلنا بـ«رواء» بفروع «إس تي سي»
طبعًا، ماخذهم حتى كقناة بيع
بالضبط، قناة بيعية
فهنا طبعًا هم يأخذون نسبة من كل جهاز يبيعونه
أكيد طبعًا يعني هي الاشتراكات قائمة
بالنهاية لازم يكون في جدوى للاثنين
ودائمًا الاشتراكات القوية اللي تدوم
أن يكون الشريك قوي يقدر يشيل الليلة معك
والنقطة الثانية، أنه ما راح يكون فيه تعارض مصالح كبيرة
على المستوى البعيد
أن استراتيجياتكم ما راح تتعارض معه
فوقتها تقدر أن تزيد اعتمادية على الشريك
شلون قدرت تقنعهم؟
هل لأن عندك خط إنتاج بيفيدهم؛ فهم حبوا يفيدونك؟
لا، قصة غريبة
بدينا في عام 2019 كنا متحمسين أنا و«عبدالله الجضعي»
في «جاي تيكس» وجالسين نعرض «رواء»
كان وقت الظاهر ما عندنا إلا ستة عملاء ممكن
وجالسين نعرض «رواء»
عندنا كذا كشك صغير
جانا واحد من شباب «إس تي سي»
سمع الفكرة ووريناه النموذج الأولي اللي يلا يشتغل
وأن هذا كاشير، وضغطة زر وينزل عبر الإنترنت المنتج
قال: والله فكرة ممتازة
أيش رأيكم تجون عندنا بـ«إس تي سي»
واعرضوا المنتج هذه، واعرضوا التقنية هذه؟
ممكن نستفيد منه بشكل معين
رحنا وعرضنا، وما ضبطت
فقال لنا: تدرون، اشتر منا أجهزة يا رجل
دام أن هذه ما ضبطت، أيش رأيكم تشترون من عندنا أجهزة بس؟
تشترون من «إس تي سي»؟
إيه، فبدينا نشتري منهم الأجهزة المحمولة باليد
حق «سونمي» ذا الصغير
فكبرت العلاقة مع الوقت
إلى أن صرنا نسحب بالألاف
سحبنا مثلًا أول 500
أنتم كنتم تبيعون الأجهزة اليدوية في البداية
إيه، عنده تطبيق، فالناس اللي عنده مثلًا
مندوب المبيعات، حق المناديب
اللي عندهم مناديب صاروا يشترون عندنا المنتجات
ونجح معنا
فكبرت علاقتكم مع الوقت
إيه، لأن صار نسحب منهم أجهزة
فصار فيه نوع من الثقة
تخيل من 2019
من يوم ما قابلنا «أبو زياد العمري» الله يذكره بالخير
حتى الظاهر القطاع غيّره الآن
إلى 2022 واحنا العلاقة نسحب أجهزة ونبيعها
هذا هو علاقتنا معهم
وصلت تقريبًا يمكن بالألاف
والله ما أدري كم الرقم
ثم سبحان الله، بمعرض «سيملس» جاء واحد من الشباب
قال: أيش تسوون مع «إس تي سي»؟
قلنا: عندنا معهم أجهزة ونسوي كذا ونسوي كذا
قال: احنا عندنا صندوق وندور فرص
احنا ممكن نستثمر
فقال: ممكن نشتغل مع بعض
صندوق «إس تي سي»
صار الصندوق هذا تبع «إس تي سي»
تمام
فيقول: ولكن احنا نستثمر بالفرص اللي فيها
توافق
بالضبط، اللي فيها علاقة استراتيجية
أنا توقعت رحت وطقيت الباب عليهم
لا، «يزيد المهيدب» كان كشافة أعتقد في ذاك الوقت
فنزل معنا وقال: لا والله فيه ترى، خلونا نشتغل
وفعلًا بدينا وصار استثمار بالأخير
يوم صار الاستثمار كبرت الشراكة مرة
صار فيه شراكة على قطاعات كثير مختلفة
«قطاف» يعني اشتغلنا على أكثر من قطاع
يعني تلقى كل شركة بـ«إس تي سي» أو كل قطاع
له علاقة بمعاملات مع الشركات صرنا نشتغل معهم بشكل أو بآخر
بس أنت هنا للتوضيح
هل تقصد «إس تي سي»
وللا «قنوات إس تي سي» وللا «الحلول» وللا من منهم؟
يا «إس تي سي» أو أحد شركات «إس تي سي»
أذكر الأجهزة مو عند «إس تي سي»
إيه الأجهزة عند «القنوات»
ولكن مثلًا «قطاف» تبع «إس تي سي»
فأنا بشتغل جميع شركات «إس تي سي»
إيه، أي شيء
العلاقة اللي بدأت في 2019
ثم بنيناها مع الشريك وصلت بالنهاية
إلى أن الشيء يكون أكبر واستثمروا بالنهاية
«إس تي سي» استثمرت بالنهاية بشكل مباشر بالشركة
أيش فيه شراكات ثانية طيب؟
البنوك مثلًا، اشتغلنا مع البنوك
فيه شراكات ممتازة مثلًا مع البنوك
ماهي بأنجح شيء
ما زال البنك يشوف أن لا، أنت توّك صغير، وشلون؟
مع أنه تتكلم أكثر من 9 مليار ريال يمر سنويًّا تقريبًا
عمليات من خلال النظام
ولكن البنك لسه يشوف أن شركة صغيرة
لا، لحظة، لكنه فيه شراكات جيدة
إن شاء الله أنها راح تكبر مع الوقت
واضح أن أنت مو مبسوط
لا، خلنا نقول فيه معاناة لسه
يعني فيه فجوة كبيرة بين سرعة مثلًا
اللي جالسة تسويه مثلًا «ساما» والمدفوعات السعودية
ويبغون أن يكون عندهم تقنيات حديثة
ويبغون يخدمون العميل بشكل جيد
وبين ردة فعل البنوك مع هذه التقنيات
ففيه يعني شوي
البنوك كلها؟
وللا أتصور فيه بنوك أتصور أصعب من بنوك؟
صح، لكن فيه مثلًا بنك يقول لك
لا والله إذا أنت مانت بحصري؛ ماني بمشتغل معك
والبنك الثاني يقول: لا، تراك أنت والله توك مثلًا...
يعني فيه تحديات كبيرة صراحة مع البنوك
لكن أنا مؤمن أنه مع الوقت
ومثلًا مع بنك «إس تي سي» ومع البنوك الرقمية
قد أنه يحسن الأمور هذه بشكل أسرع
صح، عشانهم أخوياكم عاد ما يحتاج
والله هذا اللي نتمناه احنا إلى الآن
يعني هذا اللي نتمناه
القنوات وذا ودخلوا البنك حبيبي في الموضوع
بنك «إس تي سي»
يعني هذا اللي احنا ودنا
ودنا نكون فيه خيارات كثيرة
لأن كثرة الخيارات، ويجونك ناس دماء جديدة في السوق
أكيد أنه راح يبحثون عن قنوات جديدة
طيب أيش وضع المنافسين في السوق؟
أشوف ما شاء الله السوق غرقان الحين حلول
كنت أتكلم عن المدفوعات
وكنت أتوقع وضع النقاط البيع يمكن أسوأ من المدفوعات
نتكلم عن السوق مو عنكم أنتم
لأن ما في قيمة مضافة لأغلب الموجودين
لسببٍ ما كل واحد يقول: عنده 3 ألف عميل أو ألفين عميل
مدري شلون الرقم السحري ذا
كلهم عندهم العدد ذا من العملاء
فيه حرق أسعار بشكل غير طبيعي
كل أحد يدعي يقدم أشياء قد تكون...
يعني مابي أقول الجميع
بس فيه ناس يقدمون أشياء ماهي عندهم أساسًا
يقول تعال ونسوي ذا
قفل البيعة وبعد ما نشوفهم
فيه صراحة وضع السوق سيء
أول شيء كم تشوفون تستحوذون كحصة سوقية؟
وكيف تشوفون وضعكم مقارنة بالمنافسين؟
ومين أبرز منافسينكم؟
والله شوف مشهور، أنت تقول لي لا تشخّص
فأنا أحاول أني ما أقولك وين مكاننا بالسوق
ولكن أزعم أن كثير من المنافسين دخل السوق
لأن وده يأخذ فرصة الفوترة الإلكترونية
ولكن أعظم قرار استراتيجي
وفيه كثير استفادوا منه
نوعًا ما
في المرحلة الأولى على الأقل
خل نقول أنه كان استفادة مؤقتة جدًّا
أعظم قرار استراتيجي احنا اتخذناه
هو أن ترى ما ني فوترة إلكترونية
احنا إعلاناتنا كلها ترى هذا القيمة اللي عندنا
ترى هذه الخصائص اللي عندنا
للتوضيح عشان إخواننا في هيئة الزكاة
أنت تبي فوترة إلكترونية، لكن ما تروج أنك حل ...
هذه قيمتي الوحيدة
الفوترة الإلكترونية شيء ساعدني أني أنا أقدم منتجات رهيبة مرة
حتى رتب السوق
والآن نتكلم على الذكاء الاصطناعي
ونتكلم على جودة المنتجات اللي تطلع
لأن فيه فوترة إلكترونية
فبالتالي قطعًا أنه أخذ السوق إلى بُعد مختلف
هذه يبغى لها أربع حلقات يمكن
إيه لا أكيد، بس أنا قلتها عشان...
جودتها ممتازة
موظف الزكاة اللي طلّع جواله فجأة كذا
لا، احنا نتكلم على قضية أن قيمتك الوحيدة أنك تطبع فاتورة
متوافقة مع هيئة الزكاة
وهذا حلول كثير بنوا قيمتهم على الموضوع
هذول هم اللي احنا نتكلم عنهم
اللي صاروا كثار وغرقوا السوق وهذه إعلاناتهم
احنا ترى قلنا ما نعلن أن احنا ميزتنا فوترة إلكترونية
نعلن ميزة فقط
وأزعم أنه كان صعب بالبداية
لأن تخيل عندك فرصة
فيه ناس كثير يدورون على الفوترة الإلكترونية
عندك شيء مشع، شيء لطيف وجميل
والحكومة تدعم هذا التوجه
وكان فيه بالضبط ناس تبحث كثير
كان قرار صعب
ولكن أزعم أنه من أفضل القرارات اللي احنا سويناها
أنا أعتقد أني مؤيد لك لسبب بسيط
أنا شفت كثير مثلًا خاصة بقالات ومحلات وغيره
على الأقل في أول كم شهر بعد القرار
صاروا يشترون الأنظمة هذه عشان يحطونها في المحل بس
يعني ما يستخدمونها، فأتصور...
ثم أيش صار؟
بدأ يحس بقيمة البرنامج ثم جانا
ففائدة الفوترة الإلكترونية علينا كبيرة
بس أنها غير مباشرة، صارت مثل القمع بالنسبة لنا
صار يروح للشركات اللي مو بأفضل شيء مثلًا
ويعاني ثم يجيني جاهز
حلو، من أبرز منافسينكم على كذا طيب؟
اترك هذولي اللي نتكلم عليهم، يمكن ما لهم أثر
فما ركزنا على الفوترة
لكن ركزنا على قضية التسويق للقيمة
فاليوم أنت من تشوف منافسينك في السوق؟
كأنه متخصص بالتجزئة
ومستهدف العميل اللي أنا مستهدف اليوم
أشوف «زد» مثلًا صار عندهم نظام للتجزئة
أنا أعتقد أن «زد» عميله مو نفس عميلي
نفس عميلك؟ وللا مو نفس عميلك؟
لا مو بنفسهم، بس فيه تقاطع
لأن هم عندهم منتجات كثيرة
فيه تقاطع
لكن وحدة من منتجاتهم اللي هي نقاط البيع
بس مين منافسك؟
السوق مليان أسماء، فمن تشوف الأقرب لك؟
أنا ودي تقول لي مليان وين؟
لأن أنا ودي أدور منافسين واضحين مرة بشكل مباشر
هل تعتبر «فودكس» منافس؟
ممكن مركز أكثر على المطاعم
المطاعم يعتبرون جزء كبير من عندك وللا؟
لا، يشكلون عندي نسبة مطاعم ولكنهم مو بالآلة
تقريبًا يمكن بين 50% و 60% من عملائي تجزئة
بس فيه أكيد أحد قاعدين تراقبونه وتقيسون عليه
في السعودية؟
إيه
السوق مرة مجزأ
تتذكر القاعدة اللي تكلمنا فيها
اللي هو نسبة رضا قليلة والسوق يكون مجزأ، مقطع
نسبة رضا قليلة في السوق
إيه، نسبة رضا قليلة
وبنفس الوقت السوق مشتت
ما في واحد يقود السوق
هذا اليوم «رواء» والقطاع اللي تشتغل فيه «رواء»
تعاني منه
ما في قائد للسوق واضح في السوق
اليوم في قطاع التجزئة الشركات الصغيرة والمتوسطة
ما فيه
بس فيه شركات كثيرة تحاول
ولكن أزعم أن «رواء» هي اليوم التي تقود في السوق
ومن بعد تجربتكم هذه
كم النسبة تقريبًا تربحها من كل اشتراك؟
اليوم تقدر تقول أن الهامش
تبغاها رياضيًّا وكيف أن المستثمرين يحسبونها؟
اللي تبيه شوف المناسب
لأن ما راح أقدر أتعمق معك أصلًا بالنقطة دي
الحسبة 91% تقريبًا أرباح اليوم
أوه! أيش هذا؟!
لا البرنامج عالميًا، معروف أنه عالي
شلون 91%؟
إيه، الهامش حق البرمجيات عالي
لكن كيف تحسب السؤال؟
كيف تحسب أنت؟
تشيل رواتب للتسويق، تشيل رواتب المبيعات
فقط تحسب قيمة الدعم الفني وقيمة «الخوادم»
هذا اللي كذا يحسبونها
تصير مرة
فصار هامش حقي عالي
طبعًا ليش يقولون كذا المستثمرين؟
يقولك: لأن أنت تقدر أنه لو لا سمح الله صار أي شيء
تقدر تستغني عن كل الناس هذولا
بس تبقي الدعم الفني وتبقي الخوادم
وتصير شركة ربحية
فهذا المبدأ فيها
عشان كذا دائمًا المستثمرين بس يناظرون
تكلفة الخوادم والدعم الفني
كم موظف وصلت الان؟
عدينا 250 موظف
ما شاء الله، شوف أنا يوم زرتكم
حتى ما غير تاخذون المكاتب اللي جنبكم
إيه صح، كان فيه توسع، كان فيه غزو
تحس أنه سريع التوسع والنمو
مو مرة
لأنكم دعستوا مرة
يعني خلنا نقول مثلًا انهينا سنة 2019
انهيناها مثلًا في عشرين موظف
بعدين في أربعين، خمسة وأربعين في 2020
بعدين 2021 وصلنا تقريبًا إلى 100
بعدين نهاية 2022 عدينا الـ 200 تقريبًا
يعني بين 180 و200
والآن فوق الـ 250 تقريبًا 260 وحددوها
فالنمو خلنا نقول بالنسبة للشركات الناشئة
يعتبر نمو ما راح أقولك متزن
بس أقولك نمو منطقي
فتشوفون نمو جيد
وأتوقع مجرد وجود عمليات كبيرة على المنصة
برضه تعطيكم فرص أنكم تطلعون فلوس من أماكن مختلفة
احنا قائمين على النمو
متوسط النمو عندنا في المبيعات خلال الأربعة سنوات الماضية
600% سبعة أضعاف
ما شاء الله
سبعة إكس تقريبًا
خلني قبل ما ندخل في آخر محور
ودي أسألك إذا فيه أي تقاطعات مع أي مشرعين
أذكر كان في البلدية حاطين عندهم
بعض المتطلبات للمحلات، لأنظمة الكاشير
والله شوف، الميزة السوق حقنا قطاع خاص
ومن الأشياء اللي ما ودنا ندخل في المدفوعات
عشان ما ندخل مع المشرعين فيبطئ عملية النمو
لأن كلما زادت التشريعات كلما بطئ النمو
وبعد هي ما فيها أي شيء؟
لا ما عندنا معهم بالعكس
لكنه اللي صاير أنه مثلًا يجونا الوزارات وبعض الهيئات
ويحاولون أنهم يعرضون المساعدة
فنحاول نشتغل معهم بصراحة
فالقطاع بشكل عام من جهتنا احنا ما نتعامل مع الحكومة
ما عندنا تحديات كبيرة مع الحكومة
لأن بالعكس أصلًا واضح التوجه
أن فيه دعم كبير للقطاع يمكن الشركات التقنية
سواءً كان من ناحية فلوس أو تشريعات
والله ما فيه تحديات الصراحة كبيرة
لوين رايحين؟
والله شوف التوجه نبغى نخلق قيمة حقيقية للتاجر
نبغى نكون شريك تقني حقيقي للتاجر
ما ودنا نطلع بس لأن فيه تشريعات تخدم القطاع
لا، نبغى أنه فعلًا التاجر يستفيد
بس أيش ممكن تقدم للتاجر في خطوتكم الجاية
غير الأشياء تقدمونها وغير بنك «إس تي سي»؟
مثلًا موضوع الذكاء الاصطناعي
أنا لو أحل للتاجر كيف يتخلص من قضية
أنه يدخل فواتير المشتريات عنده أو أنه يجرد
وتكون طريقة مؤتمتة وغير مكلفة
أنا أعتقد أن هذا قيمة كبيرة مرة بنقدمها للتاجر
بالإضافة إلى الأساسيات
برنامج محاسبة بتقرير ممتاز
برنامج إدارة مخزون متكامل والتبعات وملحقاته
فأني أقدم تجربة أيضًا متكاملة من البداية للنهاية
من ناحية الأجهزة الممتازة اللي تكلمنا فيها
ومن ناحية أيضًا مثلًا خدمات ما بعد البيع
تكون جيدة وإلى آخره
هذا هو الهدف الأساسي بالنسبة لنا
فعلًا يحس أنه جالس يتعامل مع شركة تحترمه
حلو، فأنت بطبيعة الحال
تركز على زيادة النمو والتجار والعمليات
بتقديم خدمات تسهل
منتجات تركز على عميل بالضبط
تركز على عميلي
ماني بطالع مثلًا إلى أشياء جديدة خلال عميلي
أي شيء يبيه عميلي بدخل به وأحاول أني أتميز فيه
يعطيك ألف عافية أبو عساف
الله يطول بعمرك
استمتعنا جدًّا باللقاء اليوم
شكرًا لك
شكرًا لكم، وشكرًا لعبدالملك آل سعيد في إنتاج المحتوى
في التحرير مرام الضبيبان
في إدارة التصوير ياسر بن غانم
في الإضاءة عبدالمجيد عمر
في الهندسة الصوتية يوسف إبراهيم
في الإخراج الإبداعي وهاب موسى
في الإخراج الفني مجد الملّي ومساعده وسيم معين
وفي الإنتاج التنفيذي غيداء التميمي
هذا بودكاست سوالف بزنس
أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع